[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
אוקיי, טוב אז שלום לכולם.
היום אנחנו בעצם. בפעם הקודמת סיימנו את הדיון שלנו די מודלי שפה.
מרקוביץ קיבלתם. אז התרגיל היום בעצם אנחנו הולכים להתחיל לעבור ל מידול הסתברותי של קבצי פיקציה.
כן, שבעיות סיווג בהתחלה זאת תהיה פיקציה יותר, כלומר מהסוג שנתקלתם בו.
באמת שיש איזשהו אוסף מחלקות לא מאוד גדול.
Changed זה אבל צריך להכליל מהם ובעצם לקראת המשך השיעור.
ככה אולי בשעה השנייה או כנראה השלישית.
נעבור גם למה שנקרא structure production, כלומר הדיקציה של מבנה אבסטרקציה של מבנה, ואנחנו נסביר למה הכוונה.
אז כן, אני מניח שכולכם כולכם כאן.
נתקלתם במושג במידה מפוקחת סופר views learning?
מישהו כאן לא נתקל בו? אוקיי, נכון, וזה אחד הדברים הבסיסיים שלומדים כשלוקחים כל קורס במיני אתם ודאי מכירים, אבל אני אחזור ממש על קצה המזלג יש לנו.
אנחנו מניחים שיש לנו Training שם פרס איזשהו אוסף של דוגמאות שהם מתויגות שם, הדגמות, הדגמות מתוך איזשהי רנדומליים Description.
נכון שאולי אין לנו גישה אליה בכלל, אבל אנחנו מניחים שכל הדוגמאות נדגמו מאותה מאותה התפלגות.
הדוגמאות האלה מגיעות יחד עם פתרון בית ספר, והמטרה שלנו זה להיות מסוגלים לבצע פיקציה מחומר של דוגמה חדשה שנדגמו מתוך ההתפלגות D.
למה זה חשוב שגם היא הדגמת מתוך ההתפלגות בין הצלחות בסטייג הקלאסי, שגם שם, בטקסט שהטקסט בדיוק נדגם באותה התפלגות הקמ אותו לא מעניין מה הדבר הנכון.
שגיאה? מה אתה רואה ככה? אוקיי, כן, אז בעצם זה עשויה להיות במקרה הקיצון קיצון.
זה יכול להיות משימה חסרת סיכוי. נכון? אם אתה אם לוקחים דוגמה שבעצם אין לה שום סיכוי אמיתי, כן, אין שום סיכוי אמיתי להיתקל בה.
בתי נמצאת ואין לה שום קשר, אז ברור שזה כנראה תהיה משוכה גבוהה מדי, למרות שצריך לומר ואנחנו גם על זה נדבר בהמשך הקורס.
צריך לומר שהמקרה הכללי, כשאנחנו עוסקים במערכות עיבוד שפה טבעית שנתקלים ביום יום, יהיה מקרי, שזה לא בדיוק מה שנקרא כן,
מה שנקרא אינדי sub ישן או אם דומיין, אלא זה משהו שיש אולי איזשהו דמיון בין ההתפלגויות, אבל לא ממש זהות.
כן? וכרגיל מה שאנחנו עושים זה כן. בסטייג הסטנדרטי אנחנו לוקחים איזשהו קורפוס שהוא מתוייג או שאנחנו מתייגים אותו.
אנחנו מחלקים אותו לשלושה חלקים Training Data Dev data וטסט Data.
נכון מפתחים את המודל על ידי אימון על ה training data ובדיקה על אותו Data מתי שאנחנו מרגישים מספיק בטוחים ורצים באמת לבדוק את זה בצורה מהימנה,
כי Development data השתמשנו בו עוד פעם ועוד פעם ועוד פעם, אז אולי מצאנו עליו.
אז אנחנו משתמשים בהם דרך test data ומדווחים תוצאות.
אוקיי, אז זה הא' ב וזה באמת הפריים מוח שאנחנו הולכים לעסוק בו כרגע.
כן, אוסף יש אוסף של דגימות, הן מתויגות וכן הלאה.
אבל ספציפית אנחנו הולכים לנקוט כאן בגישה שנקראת פרו בליסטית ספק action כן, פיקציה הסתברותית שזה אני מניח שבטח מיעוט יותר קטן מכם.
נתקלתם בו? לא. כלומר לא, עוד.
לא דיברתי על עוד שיטות שירצה. אתה כבר מדבר על על כן על ארכיטקטורות מסוימות נכון שמבוססות על רשתות נוירונים שאחרי זה נכנסים לסוף מרץ וכן הלאה.
אבל אני אוקיי, אבל בעצם השאלה באופן כללי מה זה קלאסי?
פיקציה הסתברותית כן, או שאולי אתם התחלתם באיזשהו מובן מהסוף כן, שכבר.
אוקיי, בסדר, אז אנחנו נתחיל מההתחלה. אנחנו כמובן גם נגיע ללא ג'ייס וכאלה.
אבל בוא נתחיל משלב מוקדם יותר. כן, כי בעצם מודל מודלי קלאסי, פיקציה שפולטים הסתברויות לא התחיל עם רשתות הנוירונים,
בוודאי לא התחיל עם רשתות נוירונים העכשוויות, והאבחנה הבסיסית היא בין מה שנקרא השיטה או הגישה רגנרטיבית והגישה.
הדיסקרימיננטה נאיבית? כן, שזה. אני מניח שרובכם שמעתם על המושגים האלה, נגיד בדיוק למה הכוונה בגישה הכי נרטיבית.
מה שאנחנו בעצם רוצים למדל זה את ההתפלגות המשותפת על הקשרים נמצא ועל Y.
דהיינו אנחנו גם רוצים להבין, אנחנו גם רוצים.
להבין איך לדגום דוגמאות חדשות כן או לנסות איכשהו לעשות Density cma אם כן לשערך גם את ההתפלגות שממנה הנתונים מדגמים.
כן, תחת ההנחה הקלאסית גם set וגם test, ומעצם זה שאנחנו מבטלים את ההתפלגות המשותפת כן,
אם הצלחנו לעשות את זה בצורה מתקבלת על הדעת, אז אנחנו גם יכולים לבצע באמצעות פרוטקציה נכון?
כיצד נבצע? פרוטקציה Product תתבצע על ידי מציאת הערך Max, כלומר, הלייבל הסביר ביותר שם ממקסם את ההסתברות של y בהינתן X,
שזה גם לפי חוק בייס נכון, לפי חוק בייס, אפשר גם לכתוב את זה כפי של ווי כפול פי של x.
בהינתן רווח נקי פי של x, ולפעמים הרבה פעמים באמת גם כותבים ככה פרי דיקציה במודלים גם נרטיבים נכון, כי אומרים אוקיי, הP של איקס הוא פשוט קבוע.
הוא לא משנה את הערך מקס. מה שאנחנו צריכים לעשות זה בעצם למקסם את הפרי או הלייבל יחד עם יד הענק.
כן, את המכפלה של ה prior על הלייבל. כמה לייבל הזה הוא אפריורית?
סביר או לא סביר? מרטינז, אם תרצו, כן ההתפלגות השולית של הלייבל כפול הלייף לימוד.
כלומר הסיכוי לראות את הנתונים בהינתן הלייבל שדגמנו הוא אכן הלייבל הנכון.
כן. יש סיבות יותר קלאסיות שבהן יש לזה שם קבוע.
פה זה לא ככה, לא פה זה כן ככה כל הדיון שלנו כרגע.
אנחנו בהמשך הקורס נדבר על האוטובוס. רבי יהושע. כן.
אז תודה על השאלה. זה חשוב לי מאוד להבהיר.
אני עכשיו הולך לדבר אך ורק על האם domain setting היום, כלומר על הסטייג שהצגתי פה בקצרה, אני מניח שזה גם העיקרי שבו עסקתם באימייל.
נכון בוא של כמה test set וגם chain נלקחים מתוך אותה התפלגות מה שהשארתי, אבל באמת פתחתי סוגריים ועכשיו אני סוגר סוגריים ולא לדון בזה בשיעור הזה יותר.
כן, זה שבדרך כלל כשאתם רוצים לעשות רוצים לבנות מערכת, נגיד תרגום כן או צ'אט בוט או דברים כאלה.
הרבה פעמים זאת הנחה אופטימית מדי. כן, להניח שהטקסט ואת training set מתגמלים מתוך אותה התפלגות.
כמובן שאנחנו רוצים להניח שיש בינהם איזשהי איזשהו קשר.
כן, כי אם לא יהיה שום קשר ביניהם במקרה הרע אנחנו עשויים למצוא את עצמנו עם מעט מאוד,
אבל אנחנו לא נניח זהות ביניהם, אבל זה אני סוגר את הסוגריים וכרגע אנחנו לא עוסקים בזה.
אוקיי. בסדר.
אוקיי, עכשיו במקרה של מודלים מהסוג הזה, הלמידה כן.
שוב אני אומר. ככלל, לפחות במודלים היותר פשוטים, הלמידה היא פשוטה יחסית.
הרבה פעמים אנחנו נראה שיש לנו ממש ביטוי אנליטי. כן, שבעזרתו אנחנו יכולים לשערך את המקסימום.
להיות Signature שעל זה גם תכף נדבר.
יש שיטות שמובן שמשתמשים בהן שיטות החלקה כן, כדי להתגבר על אפסים.
דברים דומים לדברים שראינו בשיעור שעבר סליחה בהקשר של אימוץ מודל, ובאופן כללי אפשר להגיד על זה שזה מודל שלם של הדאטה.
זאת אומרת, אנחנו באמת מנסים למדל גם את ההתפלגות של X, גם את ההתפלגות של Y, גם את הקשר ביניהם.
אוקיי, אז זה איזשהו complete מזה לכדי data. הגישה השנייה היא הגישה הדיסקרימיננטה, הבית כן, או לפעמים נקראים מקרים גם conditions על models.
וכאן, בהנחה שאנחנו מדברים על פיקציה הסתברותית, מה שאנחנו מנסים למדל זה אך ורק את ההסתברות של y בהינתן כן.
כלומר, אנחנו לא מנסים למדל את ההסתברות מה איזה input הוא סביר יותר או סביר פחות.
כל מה שאנחנו מנסים למדל זה את ההתפלגות של הלייבל בהינתן ש מאיפה שהוא הגיע האינפוט הזה,
ועכשיו אנחנו רוצים לחלק את המסה, את ההסתברות בין הלייבלים השונים בצורה בצורה מיטבית.
עכשיו פרדי הציע כמובן מתבצעת גם במקרה הזה על ידי ארגון Max של P של Y ומקס, אבל אין לנו.
זאת אומרת, זה אולי תיאורטית גם שווה לארג, מקס של פי של איקס סיכוי ומקס של p של y כפול p של x.
בהינתן Y וכל הדברים הקודמים שפשוט נובעים מחוק בייס, אבל זה לא ממש רלוונטי במקרה הזה, כי פשוט אין לנו.
אנחנו לא ערכים, לא הייתה שולית של לא את ההתפלגות השולית של Y, לא את ההתפלגות בכיוון ההפוך כן.
והרעיון כאן הוא בעצם כמה דברים.
דבר ראשון יש על פניו, לפחות אינטואיטיבית, איזשהו היגיון סטטיסטי בלהגיד אוקיי, מה שאני רוצה לעשות בסופו של דבר זה פיקציה.
כן, אז זה over כאילו לנסות למצוא את ההתפלגות המשותפת?
כן. למה לי גם ללמוד את זה? אני צריך כנראה יותר פרמטרים כדי לייצג גם את זה וגם את זה בצורה טובה.
כלומר, אני עשוי לסבול יותר מבעיות של דלילות נתונים.
למה לי ללכת ולחפש צרות ולנסות למדל את הג'אנק Distribution?
אם כל מה שאני צריך זה רק בעצם רק חלק מזה, נכון?
הרי מהג'וינט נגזר ההתפלגות המותנה, אבל לא ההפך.
כן, אלה דברים שאני אומר. זה דברים מוכרים לכם או שלא מוכרים?
לא מוכרים? אוקיי, אז טוב שאתם אומרים כן, אז בוא ניזכר טיפה שוב.
אני שוב ממליץ וחוזר וממליץ לחזור על החומר בהסתברות כי הוא קריטי לנו בקורס הזה, כי אין מה שאני מדבר על ואן הורן של הסתברות.
כן, הדברים הבסיסיים שלמדתם בקורס, בקורס בהסתברות.
כן, אז אני רק אזכיר p של x בהינתן סליחה של x בהינתן Y נכון?
א. אפשר לרשום אותה. ככה נכון.
ואפשר גם לרשום אותה הפוך. בסדר, זה יהיה לנו אולי קצת פחות לצרכים שלנו.
קצת פחות חשוב. אבל, אבל לפעמים כן.
ולפעמים. הם כותבים. כן כן, על ידי העברת אגפים אז לפעמים גם כותבים את מה שכתוב.
כן, זה בעצם המעבר הזה פה, מה שנקרא חוק בייס.
כן, זה פשוט להעביר אגפים בין שני.
כן, בין השוויון הזה. כן, וככלל, אתם כבר יכולים לראות מכאן שאם יש לכם את הג'וינט מודל כן, אז למקסם אותו.
כלומר, אם אני נותן לכם איזשהו איקס ואתם מנסים למצוא מה הוא היה סביר ביותר.
נכון למקסם את P של וואי הגיוני X?
אוקיי, אני נותן לכם את איקס. יש לכם עכשיו איזושהי תמונה? אתם צריכים להכריע אם זה אנטילופה?
זברה כן. כלומר הדבר הזה הוא פשוט קבוע.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו למקסם את ההסתברות של Y בהינתן X זה אותו דבר.
כמו למקסם את ההסתברות הזאת כפול קבוע חיובי שזה אותו דבר כמו למקסם את התשואה.
אוקיי, אז כל הדברים האלה שקולים, אבל מצד שני, אם יש לי רק את condition אל distribution,
רק את הסכם הנתיב model אני לא יכול עדיין לקבל את הג'וינט נכון, כי אני לא יודע אם נגיד אנטילופות יותר.
כן, רק מלדעת להבחין אפילו בצורה מושלמת.
נכון, בין זברות ל אנטילופות לא אומר לי שום דבר לגבי האם רוב התמונות בעולם הן תמונות
של או האם יש יותר תמונות בעולם או אוכלוסיית התמונות הרלוונטית של אנטילופה,
של אנטילופה או של זה נכון, זה פשוט לא אומר שום דבר.
אז אוקיי, אז זה זה הרעיון. הג'וינט מודל הוא מודל שלם, אבל יש באמת יתרונות.
לא צריך לשערך את תשאלי איקס. גם אנחנו.
נראה שיותר קל לבנות מודלים מאוד עשירים בפיצ'רים שהם מודלים עסקיים מנתיבי, לפחות תחת Framework שממנו נתחיל.
אז גם להם יש יתרונות ואנחנו נראה שאנחנו נשתמש גם באלה וגם ב יפה עכשיו מה זה מקסימום לייק להיות Destination שזה מי מביניכם שמע את המושג הזה בעבר?
אוקיי, אז כמעט כולם, אוקיי, באי מייל או במקומות אחרים באמת הרבה גבוהה בהרבה.
איפה עוד? אוקיי, אחלה.
אז זה באמת שיטת אמידה מאוד. כן, מאוד סטנדרטית, שגם יש לה תכונות סטטיסטיות מוצלחות ובעצם הרעיון של מקסימום להיטיב.
אז אם אני אומר את הדבר הבא אומר בוא נגיד שיש לנו מודל.
אנחנו רוצים לשערך נגיד Distribution. כן, התפלגות משותפת של כן מודל נרטיבית בעלות משותפת על האינסטנט סנס והלייקרס.
אוקיי, ואנחנו עכשיו מניחים שיש לנו איזשהם evidence scan איזשהו data.
כן איזשהם דגימות מתוך המודל הזה, כלומר זוגות של x או y זה מה שזה אומר דגימה מתוך הנכון מתוך המודל רגנרטיבית.
אז איך? איך מוגדר המקסימום?
אולי cut similar או male אומר ככה?
אוקיי, למודל יש כן. אנחנו כאן מניחים שיש לנו איזשהו משפחה של בעצם משפחה, של התפלגויות.
נכון שיש להם איזושהי פר מתיזה עצים, כלומר יש איזשהו פרמטר שקובע איזה בדיוק,
איזה התפלגות בדיוק אני הולך להחליט עליה נכון או איזה רשת בדיוק אני הולך לבחור.
לא משנה 3 או מרחב פרמטרים שלפיו שבו אנחנו מחפשים בעצם איזה איזה Class הפער אנחנו נבחר.
מה אנחנו נלמד והבטטה male?
כן, התת שנחשב המקסימלי כאילו לשם האיתור לפעמים יש כמה זה זה שתחת ההנחה שאלה הפרמטרים הנכונים, ההסתברות של ה evidence היא הגדולה ביותר.
אוקיי, אז זה אולי טיפה מבלבל. שומעים את זה פעם ראשונה, אבל אתם כבר שמעתם ברור לכם את זה כמה פעמים.
אז בוא נגיד בוא נגיד את זה בצורה אחרת. כן, אני אומר תראו, אני לא יודע איך העולם עובד.
כן? מה החוקיות? כאילו מה? אנדו line רגולריות של השפה או של מה שיצר את הדאטה הזה שממנו הוא הגיע ואני רוצה לשערך אותו.
כל מה שיש לי זה דגימות מתוכו. אז איך אני אניח מה אני אניח שאיך נראה באמת העולם?
איך נראה באמת התהליך הסתברותי שיצר את ה evidence כפי שאני רואה אותם.
אני העולם שבעצם העולם שמספק לי הכי הרבה הסתברות, זאת אומרת שנותן הכי הרבה הסתברות לראות את הדאטה כפי שראיתי אותו הוא העולם שאני מנחש שהוא הנכון.
כן, בסדר, כי באיזשהו מובן הוא מסביר הכי טוב את הדאטה.
כן, זאת אומרת, אם יש לי איזשהו עולם שההסתברות שלי לראות את הקמת Training Set הוא רק חצי משל עולם אחר,
אז אני אגיד שאני משערת אני המעריך שהעולם שנותן הסתברות פי 2 יותר גדולה לאבדן שראיתי הוא יותר סביר.
לכן אני רוצה לבחור אותו כנושא איזשהו היגיון אינטואיטיבי.
בלי להיכנס יותר מדי לתורה. סטטיסטית וגם במודלים סימנתי וי מגדירים באופן דומה, רק שכאן אין לנו את ההתפלגות המשותפת.
יש לנו את ההתפלגות המותנה, אבל לא משנה. עדיין יש לנו איזשהו איזשהם דגימות כנל שהם זוגות של x ו y איזשהו training data.
בעצם אנחנו קוראים לו בשפה השמאלית, אז יש לנו זוגות כאלה.
אנחנו יכולים תיאורטית לפחות לעבור כל ערך אפשרי לתת עבור כל קונפיגורציה מסוימת של הפרמטרים לבדוק מה ההסתברות של ווי,
של בעצם, של הלייבלים שאתה נמצא בהינתן האינסטינקטים של התאים.
אם זה לבחור את הפרמטרים שתחתיה, ההסתברות הזאת היא הגדולה ביותר.
שאלות לגבי חיי לבן? כן, אז זה ממש ההגדרה פשוט זה הגדרה.
על זה אנחנו מדברים כשאנחנו מדברים על Me לטוב ולרע.
בסדר, עכשיו בואו נהפוך את זה לקצת יותר קונקרטי.
אחרי שיש לנו את המושגים הבסיסיים שאנחנו יכולים להתחיל איתם ונדבר על מודל שנקרא נעיף בייס.
אוקיי, שאתם חלקכם אולי מכירים אותו שאף אחד לא.
אוקיי, אז גם בסדר, אני אלמד אותו מאפס. סתם. לפעמים אנשים נתקלים בו, למשל בביולוגיה חישובית אתה אומר ירד מעט, ירד מן הסילבוס הנוכחי.
אוקיי, אז זה בסדר. אז תגידו לי בהמשך, ככל שזה יתפתח, תגידו לי אם כן, ראיתם אותו בכל זאת?
אולי קראתם לו אחרת? אז המודל דייז בייס כן, נראה לי הכוונה.
הבנאים שהמודל הוא נאיבי, לא שביסס עצמו נאיבי, אבל זאת ככה בדרך כלל קוראים לו.
אז אוקיי, אז מה הרעיון? זה בעצם הולך להיות מודל גן נרטיבי?
כן, אנחנו הולכים למדל את ההתפלגות המשמעותית. אוקיי, כזאת המשותפת של x ו y.
אוקיי, כל x פה מוגדר וקטור של פיצ'רים וקטור סופי של פיצ'רים.
אז יש לנו איזה שהוא מימדי אוקיי של פיצ'רים תכוניות שונות.
כל אחד מהם יכול לקבל איזשהו ערך. מספר סופי של ערכים אפשריים שקראתי להם ואני הוזכר הרבה פעמים.
לצרכינו אנחנו נניח שהם אפילו אפס או אחד בינאריים, אבל זה לא משנה יותר מדי, גם אם זה סתם איזשהו אוסף סופי קצת יותר גדול.
וגם, נניח של לייבלים לקוחים מאיזשהו אוסף סופי דיסקרטי שנקרא אל גדול.
ועכשיו איך נראה המודל?
אוקיי, אז באופן כללי, כשאנחנו נדבר בקורסים על מודלים, כן, אנחנו נגדיר מודלים הסתברותיים ואתם תראו שיהיו לנו הרבה מודלים הסתברותיים בקורס.
אנחנו נרצה לדבר על כמה דברים. אוקיי, אנחנו נרצה לדבר.
דבר ראשון, איך נראה המודל? מה הכוונה? איך נראה המודל? כלומר איזה הסתברות מקבל Instant מסוים אם לייבל מסוים תחת השמה מסוימת לפרמטרים?
אוקיי, זה פשוט אומר איך נראה המודל? אז זה דבר אחד שאנחנו נרצה להגדיר.
אוקיי, הדבר השני שאנחנו נרצה להגדיר זה איך אנחנו מאמנים את המודל הזה.
או במילים אחרות איך אנחנו משרתים את הפרמטרים בהינתן Training Data, אנחנו לא כל כך נעסוק באן סופר וייס קצת בסוף.
בינתיים אנחנו נעסוק בסופר בייס Learning, אלא אם נאמר אחרת.
כלומר יש לנו Changing data ואנחנו מתעניין בשאלה איך בהינתן string data אומדים את הפרמטרים נכון, מה שנקרא למידה ואנחנו מתעניין ב ניחוש.
מה עוד אני צריך להגיד כדי להגדיר מודל? הגדרתי איך נותנים הסתברויות לאינטרסים בהינתן פרמטרים הגדרתי איך מתבצעת הלמידה.
יש עוד אלמנט חשוב לפני שנוכל להפעיל אותו. איך מתבצע Influence?
כן. איך מתבצע עסק? אוקיי. כלומר, בהינתן שיש לי מודל ממומן קבעתי ערכים מסוימים לפרמטרים.
עכשיו קיבלתי מה? זוכרים מה זה עסק יפרנס?
לא. אוקיי. אולי קראתי לזה בשם אחר. אם כבר אין ספרי דיקציה, פשוט כן.
בהינתן עכשיו X אני רוצה לנצל את ה y הסביר ביותר שעבור אותו x בסדר זה נקרא אינפורמציה לבין זכויות.
אוקיי, אז זה ההבדל. המודל, כלומר הדרך שבה בהינתן x ו y איזשהו x ו y והסכמה מסוימת לפרמטרים תטא אתה מחשב את ההסתברות של x ו y.
בהינתן שהפרמטרים הם תטא, כן, כאן יהיה איזושהי נוסחה.
במקרים אחרים תהיה נוסחה אחרת. ואני קורא לזה פשוט להגדיר את המודל.
זה מה שנקרא הגדרת המודל. אוקיי. דבר שני שאנחנו צריכים אלמנט שני שהוא הכרחי זה למידה.
כלומר יש לנו find a תשובה ואיסלאם אלא אם נאמר אחרת.
כלומר יש לנו, ציין Insert, ואנחנו רוצים להגדיר איך אנחנו משרתים את תטא בהינתן training והשלישי זה pre דיקציה.
מה אומר את הפרי? דיקציה פרי דיקציה אומרת אני נותן לך תטא ואיקס.
אני לא אומר לך מה Y. זה השוני. כאילו מהשלב הראשון שדיברנו ועכשיו תמצא לי את הY שהוא ממקסם את ההסתברות המשותפת או הסתברות המותנה.
תלוי אם זה הנרטיב להיות בסכמה טבעי. בהינתן X.
בסדר, לפעמים זה יהיה קל מאוד ולפעמים זה יהיה די מסובך אז אנחנו נראה טוב.
יפה נגדיר את המודל.
אז במקרה הזה מודל ניווט בייס אומר את הדבר הבא הוא מניח שההתפטרות המשותפת של X או Y מתפרקת באופן הזה מתפרקת כפי של Y, כפול מכפלה על פני הפיצ'רים.
אוקיי של ההסתברות של הפיצ'ר. ג'יי בהינתן Y.
במילים אחרות כן, אם תשימו לב מה אנחנו בעצם מניחים כאן, אנחנו מניחים אי תלות מותנה.
אנחנו מניחים שבהינתן עליהם הפיצ'רים הם בלתי תלויים.
אוקיי, אז זאת הנחת רדיקלית.
כן, אם תחשבו על זה, יש לכם אתם. מה אתם אומרים? יש לי פה כל מיני אינסוף אנשים.
הם מחולקים איכשהו למחלקות. כן, אבל.
אבל בתוך אותה מחלקה כן, בתוך אותה מחלקה כל הערכים של הפיצ'רים.
אין ביניהם שום קשר סטטיסטי. כן, אין שום קשר הסתברותי ביניהם.
כל אחד מקבל בתוך אותה מחלקה אוסף לגמרי בלתי.
כן, התכונות השונות שלהם לגמרי בלתי תלויות.
אין ביניהם שום קשר סטטיסטי. יפה. אוקיי, אז זאת הנחה די רדיקלית, אבל לפעמים הנחות רדיקליות זה דבר טוב, כי לפעמים זה מספיק טוב וזה מפשט את המודל.
אז נתחיל דווקא בשלב הזה. סליחה, הייתי צריך לומר עוד משהו, זה שלצרכן הוא כאן.
אנחנו תכף נראה את זה לצרכינו. כאן אנחנו גם נניח שה ההתפלגויות האלה הם פשוט מולטי נעמי.
כל אחד מהאלמנטים כאן הוא פשוט פלטינום. כלומר זה איזושהי התפלגות דיסקרטית.
כן, על כך וכך ערכים. נגיד יש לנו 10 אייברסון p של Y הוא פשוט איזשהי התפלגות על עשרה ערכים.
כן, כלומר מספרים שליליים שמסתיימים ל 1. כנל לגבי p של הפיצ'רים הכל Y.
אנחנו תכף נראה את זה יפה. איך מתבצע אם מפרנס כרגיל אינפורמציה אנחנו צריכים למקסם את ההסתברות המשותפת של x ו y כן או את ההסתברות של y בהינתן x,
אבל ראינו שכל הצורות השונות האלה שקולות.
וכן במקרה כאן יהיה לנו נוח להשתמש דווקא בצורה הזאת, כי פשוט יהיה לנו ממש ביטויים מפורשים לפי של y ושל p של x בהינתן Y.
כן, אנחנו תכף נראה דוגמה, אבל אנחנו ממש הולכים לשערך את ההתפלגויות האלה גם לפי של את הגורם הראשון פה בהתפלגות וגם את האלמנטים האלה.
כן, את כל הפקטורים במכפלה הזאת כמכפלה אתם פשוט p של x בהינתן y ובמקרה כאן פרדי קציעה או influence הוא מאוד פשוט.
יש לנו נגיד 10 מחלקות. יש לנו שהערכנו את הפרמטרים.
כלומר אנחנו עכשיו יודעים איך לחשב את p של y ואנחנו יודעים איך לחשב את p של x.
בהינתן Y נעבור לייבל מספר אחד נחשב את כן לייבל מספר אחד נחשבת p של y, עכשיו p של x.
בהינתן Y נרשום בצד מספר שתיים. כאן מספר שלוש מספר ארבע קיבלנו בסוף עשרה מספרים.
נעשה עליהם מקסימום האינדקס שזכה או מה שזה.
אוקיי, מאוד פשוט, אבל עדיין אני מציין את זה כי אתם תראו שככל שהקורס יתקדם, הסיפור הזה לא יהיה בהכרח כל כך פשוט.
יפה עכשיו איך נראים הפיצ'רים?
כן. אז בוא בוא ניקח דוגמה קונקרטית כדי להפוך את זה לקצת פחות אבסטרקטי, ואז גם נדבר על איך מתבצעת הלמידה.
אז נגיד שאנחנו רוצים לבצע טקסט רציף באמצעות בהגברה.
אז כן, זה אחד המודלים הכי בסיסיים שיש בהן NP מאוד פשוט.
מצד שני, הרבה פעמים הוא מספיק טוב. כן, אבל הוא.
מהיר כמו ברק. כן, אתם תראו. נורא פשוט.
מה הרעיון כאן? הרעיון הוא כזה לפעמים כדי לבצע Class היא פיקציה של מסמכים.
כל מה שמספיק לראות זה איזה מילים יש בהם, איזה מילים יש בהם או אין בהם?
אוקיי, לדוגמה, נגיד שאתם רוצים לקחת איזשהו קטע מהעיתון ולהחליט האם זה מגיע ממדור הספורט או ממדור הכלכלה או ממדור הפוליטיקה או לא יודע מה.
כן מדור לא משנה נגיד שאחר. אפילו סתם אני זורק.
בעצם הרבה פעמים כל מה שמספיק לכם זה לדעת איזה מילים מופיעות שם.
כן, כי אם יש שם הרבה מילים שהם שמות של ספורטאים או שמות של ענפי ספורט או כל מיני כאלה, סיכוי די טוב שהוא ספורט.
כן? ואם יש שם שמות של טכניקות ציור ולא יודע סגנונות מוזיקליים אז אולי זה מהתרבות וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז סך הכל מסתבר שלפעמים זה מספיק טוב.
ואז מה שאנחנו בעצם צריכים זה לייצג כל מסמך פשוט כפקטור של אפסים ואחדים אפילו.
בוא נגיד שאפילו שברמה הבסיסית אנחנו אפילו מתעניינים בתדירות.
כן, בסדר. אפשר גם להרחיב את זה שיכלול את התאימות. זה לא מסבך את זה משמעותית, אבל הרעיון הוא זה שאנחנו, כל מילה יכולה להופיע או לא להופיע וזה פיצ'ר.
כן. אז כל מילה באוצר המילים. כן אוסיף כאן שהיא דוגמה קצת מטופשת, אבל תניחו שכל אחד מאלה זה פשוט מסמך באופן יותר כללי הוא יותר ארוך ככה הוא מאוד קצר.
יוסי לייק! ספר זין על האקס אנג'לס דן. סליחה, התכוונתי לדינה.
אוקיי, דין על איקס Apple זה לא ריינג'רס. אז בעצם אה, אוקיי, יש לי גם דנה.
אה, סליחה, יש לי גם דנה כן, שנייה אחת אני רק אענה.
לא לא, זה לא טייפ ארוך. אז עכשיו אוצר המילים שלי, כלומר פיצ'רים של איזה הופעה או הופעה של יוסי, דינה ודנה.
Like Apple, orange and ובוב?
אוקיי, וכל אחד מהמסמכים האלה אני יכול לייצג אותו.
פשוט וקטור של אפסים ואחדים באפס אחד בחזקת.
8. אוקיי, אז זה הפיצ'ר פרזנטציה? כן.
אז זהו, שלקחתי את המערכת וגם את הפלטפורמה בפועל ככל זה זה מודל די חלש.
בוא נאמר ככה לא הייתי מציע לך לייצר מסמך באמצעות המודל נרטיבי, כאילו זה מצחיק מאוד.
כנראה שזה מה שבפועל לא הרבה פעמים פשוט הזהות של המינים אחד מארבעת המינים.
אתה מתכוון לומר אני לא יודע. אני יודעת שיוסי הופיע במשחק האחרון, אבל נכון בדיוק בשביל הרבה בשביל כל מיני מחלקות שהן יחסית מובחנות.
אתה לא צריך את זה. כן, תחשוב שיש לך את מדור הספורט בעיתון ואת מדור הכלכלה בעיתון.
מאוד יכול להיות שבסדר.
יכול להיות שפתאום יופיע איזה מניות או שם של מניה במדור הספורט, אבל סך הכל יפה לך כנראה מספיק מלים כדי שתבין שזה ספורט ולא כלכלה ולהפך.
אוקיי, זה בערך הרעיון ויש כאן עוד הנחה באמת.
אז יש את ההנחה הזאת שהיא קשורה לפיצ'ר יפה תשע נכון, אני לא יודע איפה המילים נמצאות, אני אפילו לא יודע כמה פעמים מופיעות.
אני רק יודע אם מופיע או לא מופיע, אבל מה שמעניין אותי לצרכן הוא זה שגם בעצם,
ברגע שאנחנו הולכים להמשיג את זה בתור מודל נגיב בייס, אז אנחנו גם הולכים להניח של לייבלים הם בלתי תלויים בראש הפיצ'רים.
סליחה, הם בלתי תלויים אחד בשני בהינתן הלייבל.
אוקיי, כלומר, מה שאני הולך להניח כן, זה שההסתברות של זוג של לייבל ו feature פקטור לייבל במסמך זה דה מרטינז של Y כפול מכפלה על כל אחד מהפיצ'רים.
כן על הערך שלו, האם הוא סביר או לא סביר? עכשיו תחשבו על זה שזה משהו קצת מוזר.
בוא ניזכר למשל במדור הספורט איזה מילים אולי הופיעו במדור הספורט, נגיד במדור ספורט של היום, נגיד לנצח לנצח?
אולי כן ואולי יופיע ג'ודו.
נגיד היה לנו כמה הישגים באליפות אירופה בג'ודו. אולי ידונו בזה?
כן. ד. כן, מדליה בדיוק ודברים כאלה.
יפה עכשיו ההנחה מה הנחה של המודל אומרת נכון, זה שבהינתן שאני כבר יודע שזה מדור הספורט, כן.
אז בעצם הפיצ'רים הסבירות של מילים שונות.
כן, זה שאני אוקיי, נגיד, אני אומר לך הנה יש לי עכשיו פה מסמך, אל תסתכל עליו.
אוקיי, אני אומר לך, יש בו את המילה ג'ודו והוא ממדור הספורט.
זה הסכמנו. כן, יש את המילה ג'ודו. זה לא נותן לך שום מידע על איזה עוד מילים מופיעות שם?
זה קצת מוזר, נכון? כי אם נגיד מופיע ג'ודו אז אולי מופיע איפון.
נכון, זה מאוד.
אתה רוצה להציג אותן בצורה של ג'יבריש לעומת כתבה אמיתית.
נכון, אבל זה אני אומר זה ניחא. כי כי כאן צריך להבחין.
כן המודל הסתברותי הזה. אתה צודק שהוא מודל גן נרטיב.
כלומר, לכאורה אני יכול לדגום ממנו.
נכון, אני ממשיך לדגום ממנו מסמכים. יש לי את המודל. אני יכול לשמש בקר מודל שפה למעשה הן סוג של מודל שפה.
נכון, אני מחליט מה לייבל, נגיד, זורק מטבע, מחליט אם זה ספורט או כלכלה או זה.
עכשיו אני פשוט מתחיל לפלוט מילים, כי מה שקרה לנו היום נקרא מודל נכון.
אז עכשיו אני אני מתחיל לפלוט מילים. לא כדאי לך לעשות את זה כי זה יהיה מסמך גרוע מאוד.
אבל אתה אומר תראה, זה נכון, אבל בעצם כל מה שאני רוצה מהמודל הזה זה שהוא יהיה מודל שאתה בכלל פיקציה.
כלומר, זה נכון שהוא מודל גן נרטיבי, אבל אני הולך להשתמש בו בצורות הסכם נתיבי.
ואז אני אומר בסדר, אז זה שהוא מוציא ג'יבריש אני יכול לחיות עם זה?
כן, אבל אימה? אולי יהיה לי קצת קשה לחיות עם זה שאפילו כשאני נותן לו את איקס כן, בעצם אני.
אני נותן לו את X. ואני אומר לך כאילו זה עכשיו setting.
נכון אתה מודל לי. יש פה בצד את איקס.
אוקיי, ועכשיו אתה בוחן לייבל מסוים, נגיד ספורט מול כלכלה.
אתה רוצה להחליט מה מהם יותר סביר? כן. אז מה שאני אומר לך זה שאם אתה עכשיו כדי, בעצם אם אתה שוקל איזשהו.
אתה שוקל איזשהו לייבל מסוים. אין שום אסוציאציה בין ההופעה של מילה אחת להופעה של מילה אחרת.
אוקיי, בהינתן לייבל ברור שמראש יש קשר.
זאת אומרת, אם אין בכלל שום קשר בין הופעה של מילים לבין הלייבל, כלומר גם בלי ההתניה, אז אני אהיה מודל מאוד מאוד גרוע, נכון?
כי מה זה אומר? כן, הפיצ'רים לא רלוונטיים, נכון?
כי אז ברור שאת זה אנחנו לא מניחים. כן, זה ברור, זה אפילו מודל לא רע, אני אומר בנסיבות מסוימות,
אבל אנחנו כן מניחים הנחה שהיא בכל זאת סבירה, אבל עדיין מאוד רדיקלית, כי הם בלתי תלויים בהינתן עדיפות.
אוקיי, יפה. כלומר ההסתברות אם אני רוצה לבצע Influence מה שאני צריך לעשות זה בעצם לקחת, ויש לי כבר את הפרמטרים של המודל.
כלומר יש לי את המולטי נהוג גם של הפריוס וגם את ההסתברות לכל מילה להופיע בהינתן לייבל, אז מה שאני רוצה לעשות זה לעבור על כל הווים האפשריים.
נגיד 10 עשרה מדורים בעיתון שיש לי כל אחד מהם להסתכל על הפריוס.
כן, כמה סביר אפריורית. אולי מדור מסוים יש רק נורא, מעט עם סמסים שלא בסופי ההתפלגות שלי.
ועכשיו אני הולך לכפול את מכל המילים שמופיעות באיקס.
כן, שמופיעות במסמך שלי על ההסתברות שהאקס Word הפיצ'ר הזה שווה אחד עבור אותו Y.
אוקיי, זה לעבור על כל המילים שלא מופיעים במסמך שלי ולהסתכל על האפשרות שהם אפס.
כלומר שהיה הפיצ'ר הזה הוא אפס בהינתן הלייזר וזהו.
ועכשיו אני רוצה את המקסימום לצאת RX בסדר, עכשיו שימו לב שבאמת אם זה באמת בינארי כמו כאן, אז בעצם כן, מספיק לשמור רק סט אחד מהם.
נכון, מספיק לשמור או את ההסתברויות של אחד או את ההסתברות של אפס.
שני זה אחד מינוס. אם יש לי יותר ערכים צריך לשמור.
אם יש לי לא יודע מביא ערכים אני צריך מביא פחות אחד.
אוקיי, בסדר. אוקיי, מעולה עכשיו איך אנחנו לומדים?
איך אנחנו לומדים את הפרמטרים של המודל? אז דבר ראשון מה הם הפרמטרים של המודל?
אז זה אמר זה ה prior על פני הקלאסים?
כן על פני הלייבלים וזה הסתברות של Feature לקבל נגיד אחד כי אמרנו שאפס אחד מינוס זה.
אז ההסתברות של הפיצ'ר הזה הוא אחד בקלאס עבור כל כן באותו Class שאנחנו בוחנים עכשיו אנחנו מניחים שיש לנו אין כרגיל.
אנחנו מניחים שיש לנו. אין דוגמאות מדויקות, נכון, ואנחנו רוצים להשתמש ונגיד במקסימום smartphone,
אז אנחנו צריכים לרשום את הלייט נייט של הצהריים איתם ולחפש את המקסימום על הפרמטרים נכון, בהינתן זה.
אז איך ככה נקרא לי עליי תיעוד? כן, תגידו לי אם ככה גם כתבתם את זה בימין וכאלה בדרך כלל לא.
אוקיי, לא משנה ככה אנחנו נכתוב את זה בקורס הזה. מקווה שזה לא שונה מידי.
ומה מהצורות שלמדתם זה מה אנחנו אומרים. אוקיי, איך נראית פונקציית הלייק?
לרוב היא פשוט אנחנו מניחים שבדרך כלל אנחנו נניח האינסטינקטים השונים בטריינינג סתם בלתי תלויים אחד בשני.
כלומר הליכוד של כל הקשרים עם ספי, מכפלה על הלייק לגודל של הדוגמאות, אימון הספציפיות.
כל אחת מהם מתפרקת. כן, כפי של Wi.
של x היא בהינתן WiFi וזה בכל אחת מאלה.
אנחנו מניחים שמתפרק. כן. כמכפלה על הפיצ'רים ו.
אוקיי, ועכשיו יש לנו איזשהו ביטוי נכון. תזכרו שפי של Wix הם ידועים.
נכון, יש לנו פה את הפונקציה הזאת. זה בעצם פונקציה של מה.
זה פונקציה של כאילו של הווקטור שממש הווקטור של הY לכל הווקטור של הערכים האפשריים של Y.
בסדר, אז כאן תחשבו ש wii זה נגיד לא יודע מספורט.
אוקיי, וכאן כתוב הופעה של המילה זברה בהינתן שזה ספורט.
אוקיי, הפרמטרים שלי זה פשוט.
מהי ההסתברות הזאת? כן. מהו הערך הזה במולטי תינוק?
כן, וזה מה שאנחנו רוצים למקסם.
אפשר לגזור את זה וזה די פשוט לעשות את הדרך ציה ואנחנו לא נעשה אותה כאן.
תרגיל אופטימיזציה פשוט מה שרואים זה שיש ביטוי אנליטי פשוט ביטוי סגור למקסימום, והביטוי הזה הוא נראה בצורה ניכרת.
אם תסתכלו הוא אומר ככה, מה הוא? מה הוא השערוך של אטריום?
של התפלגות השולטת על Y? לפי האמן לי זה פשוט מספר הפעמים בפלייליסט שיופיע אותו לייבל חלקי סך כל מספר training.
אוקיי, נגיד למשל, אם ב training set הופיע 20 אחוז דוגמאות ממדור הספורט ועשרה אחוזים מדור כלכלה, ההסתברות לספורט אפריורית תהיה אפס.
נקודה. שתיים בייסבול לקולקטיב 1 בסדר. ולגבי הפיצ'רים רעיון דומה מה ההסתברות שהמילה הג'יי תופיע?
כלומר שפיטר איקס ג'יי אחד?
בהינתן שעלי בלו A, זה מספר הפעמים שבהם בעצם השכיחות היחסית של הופעה של המילה הזאת בתוך הטי נמצאת בתוך הטרנינג סנצ'ז שהיו מתויגים K בסדר.
כלומר, זה יכול להיות שכיחויות יחסיות וזה מה שיוצא שגם ממקסם את המקסימום likely עוד.
וכמובן שכרגיל אנחנו צריכים להפעיל פה איזשהו סמול. ואם ככלל, למה בעצם?
אוקיי, נכון. דבר ראשון, כי אולי באמת יש לנו מילים שפשוט לא הופיעו מעולם בתי כנסת אחרים.
כן כן, לפעמים אולי נחלק באפס ממש.
אם יש לנו מספר גדול של רייבנס, אולי אפילו לא נתקלנו בחלקם כן.
ואפילו ובוא נגיד שאין לנו ממש אפסים. למה עוד?
למה למה? אולי אפילו אז נרצה לעשות שמוביל.
כן. אוקיי, אז תזכיר לנו כמה דברים טובים.
וואי אני סובל! כן.
אוקיי, אז בעצם אולי אנחנו לא רוצים? כן. אז בעצם אנחנו איכשהו צריכים לקחת בחשבון שיש לנו איזשהו.
דגימה סופית נכון, ולכן יכול להיות שפשוט מעצם הדגימה קיבלנו כל מיני.
כל מיני סרטיפיקטים. נגיד היה לנו אני לא יודע מה.
אלף מסמכים. סליחה, כן אלף מסמכים, בתי Insert ולא יודע נגיד 100 בכל קטגוריה.
ויצא לנו שנגיד למשל במדור הספורט פעם אחת הופיע נגיד.
באחד המסמכים האלה הופיע המילה ג'ירפה. נגיד.
אני לא יודע אם ג'ירפה פרצה לאיזשהו מגרש ספורט איפשהו.
לא יודע למה. אוקיי, אז עכשיו יש לנו. אז מה ההסתברות עכשיו של הופעת המילה ג'ירפה במדור הספורט?
לפי האם אני מצד אחד חלקי מאה כן, נגיד זה אחד חלקי 10 פה ההסתברות פה זניחה.
כן, אבל כל המבוססת על הרנסנס אחד בודד.
ברור שאנחנו רוצים קצת להחליק וכן טיפה להוריד את האפקט של דברים מוזרים כאלה.
בסדר, אז זאת הגישה רגנרטיבית לפחות. המודל הפשוט ביותר בגישה הזאת.
נאיבי. סמארט גישת דיסקים מנתיבות.
אוקיי, אז בגישה נרטיבית מכל מיני סיבות שמי שמתעניין בהם אני בהחלט ממליץ לו מאוד ללמוד את הקורס.
מודלים גרפים הסתברותיים שאני מקווה שינצל שנה הבאה שם לומדים את זה פשוט מאוד לעומק או מי שרוצה.
גם אני מפנה לספר. מי שמתעניין במדעים הסתברותי יצא טקסט בו כבר לפני לא מעט שנים, אבל הוא עדיין ככה.
את הבסיס מעביר בצורה מצויינת שגם הוא נקרא פה בלי סיכוי.
הפרק על מודל של קולר ופרידמן או פרידמן זה קולר.
והוא קיים בספרייה גם וכאלה.
אז מי שמתעניין בהחלט ממליץ, אבל אני ככה אגיד לכם אפילו לצרכי הקורס הזה שיש בעיה שם כי יש בעיה בלהכניס פיצ'רים מורכבים מדי במודלים מגן נרטיבי,
כי בגדול מה שאנחנו צריכים לעשות זה זה איזה שהוא מודל שבעצם להנדס איזשהו מודל שממנו אנחנו יכולים לדגום את התת אוקיי,
אבל אם יש לכם איזשהו סט גדול של פיצ'רים שיש להם כפילויות מאוד מורכבות אחד בשני, כן, ואתם איכשהו רוצים לדגום אותם אחד אחד באיזושהי צורה,
כי אין אתם לא רוצים לדגום את הכל בוכטה, כי פשוט יש מספר עצום של קונפיגורציות אפשריות.
אז בעצם מה תצטרכו לעשות? תצטרכו לדגום את הפיצ'ר.
עכשיו אתם רוצים לדגום דוגמת אימון שערכתם?
את ההתפלגות אתם רוצים לדגום דוגמת אימון בסדר מהתפלגות שערכתם אז אתם אוקיי, אז דגם אתם את הפיצ'ר הראשון לפי ההתפלגות השולית שלו.
אוקיי, אבל עכשיו אתם צריכים את ההתפלגות המותנה של הפיצ'ר השני.
בהינתן הפיצ'ר הראשון, ההתפלגות המותנית של הפיצ'ר השלישי בהינתן שני הראשונים וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, עכשיו, אם הם בלתי תלויים, בהינתן הלימה כמו בנייס בייס אין שום בעיה.
נורא פשוט. נכון, זה תמיד עובד לי. לא משנה לי שכבר הדגמתי 5000 פיצ'רים קודם.
הם לא משפיעים לי בכלל על הדגימה.
אם יש איזה שהיא תלות שהיא לא כל כך פשוטה, אבל עדיין ממד שכל אנחנו נראה כאלה בהמשך הקורס גם בסדר, אבל אם יש איזה תלויות נורא מורכבות, אתם בבעיה.
בגדול אתם בבעיה. כן, המודל הדיסקרימיננטה ביבי עוקף באלגנטיות את הסיפור הזה, כי בעצם אתם לא צריכים מודל שאפשר לדגום ממנו דוגמאות.
כן, הפיצ'רים נכון, הם פשוט input. אין לכם שום ידע על ההתפלגות שיצרה את המסמסים?
כל מה שאתם מנסים למדל זה את ההתפלגות של y בהינתן x, ולכן אם אתם רוצים להשתמש בפיצ'רים מורכבים,
בייחוד שיש ביניהם קורלציה וכל מיני מבנה תלויות מורכבים, כנראה שהדרך של דרך המלך מבחינתכם היא להשתמש במודל במודל הסכם נתיב.
מהו המודל הדיסקרימיננטה?
הבעיה הפופולרי ביותר, בוא נאמר, הפופולרי ביותר בכל הזמנים, ועדיין נמצא בשימוש נרחב למרות כל רשתות הנוירונים, מה שנקרא מודל הלוג ליניארי.
כן, לא גלינקא. המודל שאולי נתקלתם בו בעבר, אולי בשם אחר.
נתקלתם בשם הזה או לא?
אוקיי, אולי אתם תכירו אותו בשמות אחרים. לפעמים קוראים לו מקסימום אנטרופי מודל או אתם תראו אוקיי, משפחה אקספוננציאלית, לוגיסטיקה, מגרשים.
לפעמים הוא מין. הוא לא מקרה שהוא תת טיפוס שלו או סוג מסוים שלו.
אבל אוקיי, תכף אתם אתם תראו ואולי זה יראה מוכר, אז אנחנו עדיין עוסקים באותה בעיה.
יש לנו אוסף של מסמכים, יש לנו אוסף של קטגוריות.
איזושהי התפלגות מהמסמכים והאם מה שאנחנו רוצים זה באמצעות.
סוג של גישת בגבוה? כן, זאת אומרת, באיזושהי צורה יחסית פשוטה, בלי ממש למדל את כל המבנה המורכב של השפה ושל המסמך למבנה הרטורי.
ואני לא יודע מה והדיסק פסיבי. אנחנו רוצים להכריע האם מדובר בפוליטיקה או בספורט או באחר.
נגיד או אולי עוד כמה מחלקות. ואנחנו אומרים בסדר, אז אם אתה בגופו את זה ממש הבסיסי, נכון שהבגרות זה בסיסי?
אני שואל לפני פייסט פשוט אומר מילה. הוא מופיעה או שהיא לא מופיעה?
זה הפיצ'ר, ככה אני מייצג, אבל זה די מוגבל.
נכון? כי אולי יש עוד כל מיני דברים שהיינו רוצים,
אבל הם לא בלתי תלויים במילה בי אפילו מילים זהות שהמילים הם לא באמת בלתי הם לא באמת בלתי תלויות כמו שראינו קודם.
על אחת כמה וכמה אם אנחנו מכניסים עוד כל מיני דברים שברור שיש ביניהם קורלציה כמו נגיד אורך המסמך או Average Word.
כן, אורך מילה ממוצע. אולי זה רלוונטי לקלאסי מסוימים או מאיפה מגיע המסמך, או איך הוא בדיוק נראה נכון.
כי אם הוא נראה Layout שלו, כמה פסקאות יש בו וכמה רווחים, זה כנראה קשור לעורך שלו.
כן, והעורך שלו אולי קשור לדברים אחרים וכאילו וכן הלאה.
יותר גרוע מזה הרבה פעמים אנחנו ממש רוצים פיצ'רים שהם מקודדים, את אותם את אותו מידע בדיוק או כמעט בדיוק בדרך אחרת.
כן, אז למשל נגיד שיש לכם את המסמך, הנה קטע מתוך איזשהו מסמך פוטנציאלי וושינגטון Country ג'ל סבתא לבן,
סרטון וואן אנטי Six Six מיילס לסמן הפיקה דה טרנסלייט, סופי לאנג שם פונטי פיבוט טוויטר עם סטייל Secret One Day.
אוקיי, אז יכול להיות שכרגיל אתם רוצים, כמו בבאג, פורץ לקודד את זה שמופיע שם גיל ומופיע שם Count ומופיע שם פילדינג וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אבל יכול להיות שעכשיו, אם אתם נגיד שזה אז משימת פרס היא פיקציה שלכם.
אוקיי, זה משימת קלסי פיקציה שקשורה לאיזושהי מילה מסויימת במסמך.
אוקיי, נגיד, אני אומר לכם, הנה מסמך הנה מילה מסוימת יפה Bold Face Serve.
אוקיי, ואני רוצה שאתם תגידו לי משהו על המילה, על שימוש במילה server בהקשר הזה.
אוקיי, נגיד למשל, אולי מהמובן בדיוק שמשתמשים בו או משהו או משהו שקשור אליה.
אוקיי, אז יכול להיות שאתם לא רוצים לתת את אותו מעמד לכל המילים במסמך.
אולי אתם רוצים להגיד מה שקרוב אליה? אוקיי, אז מה שמגניב היא לא בקונטקסט.
הוא צריך לקבל סט של פיצ'רים אחרים. אוקיי, אז עכשיו ג'יילס נגיד יופיע בתור Local קונטקסט אחד, אבל אולי איזושהי מילה שמופיעה בהמשך המסמך לא יודע.
מה לא יודע. הוואן פאוור פוינט היא היא כבר רחוקה, אז היא מופיעה כאחד בקונטקסט נקודתיים 1210, אבל היא לא מופיעה בלא כל קונטקסט.
היא מופיע שם כאפס. אוקיי, ואולי אפילו אנחנו רוצים לעשות עוד אחד שלישי שאנחנו אומרים תראו, מיוז הוא המוסף של סרט כן וסוף.
די. המילה שעכשיו מעניינת אותי. אז זה לא אני. אתן מעמד אפילו עוד יותר מיוחד באיזשהו מובן.
וכך רק פיצ'רים שהם מוסה או הנושא או לא יודע מה.
אז אתם מבינים אותו מידע כמעט נכון מקודד עוד פעם בעוד פיצ'ר ובעוד פיצ'ר ועוד פיצ'ר.
ויש בזה היגיון. כן, כי זה הוא עדיין אולי מספק לי קצת אינפורמציה.
לדעתי מילה מסוימת מופיעה במסמך.
אבל, אבל אני עדיין רוצה לתת מעמד אחר לכאלה שהם ממש מופיעות קרוב וכאלה, ועוד יותר שהן נמצאות בקשר תחבירי הדוק עם המילה הרלוונטי.
נגיד שפה אוקיי, או בהקשרים אחרים, יהיה לנו גם פיצ'רים שהם יהיו נקרא מה זהות המילים במסמך וגם בית גם כן פשוט.
מה הזהות של הזוגות שלי במסמך? כן, איזה זוגות של מילים מופיעות במסמך?
זה גם רלוונטי באיזה שלושת של מין. עכשיו ברור שיש קורלציה.
כן? אם איזושהי מילה לא מופיעה במסמך אז גם כל הזוגות ושלישיות ורביעיות שמקיימים את המילה הזאת לא מופיעות במסמך.
נכון, זה חשוב, כן תלות, אין תלות יותר חזקה מזאת, אבל אנחנו אולי נרצה את כולם כי כל אחד מהם נותן לנו עוד איזה שהוא אקסטרה הבנאי הקודמים.
ועכשיו אנחנו רוצים איזשהו מודל נרטיבי שיידע להתמודד עם זה בצורה יחסית אלגנטית, ועל זה נדבר.
אחרי הפסקה נמצא לרבע שעה הפסקה. כן.
לא אדם. למידה מודל למידה כזה או מודל בסיכון גבוה?
למדת?
לשערך כפי שבוודאי יש הסתברות של פינצ'ר בהינתן שכל היה במחיצת פחות או יותר זמנים על כל אחד נכון ולאחר המדידה שקובע איזה מודל ספציפי אתה תקבל מתוך שמחה.
זה. לאחר. תקופה קצרה עלה מפלס.
כאילו לא רואים אותך.
אתה רוצה אותי? לא כל כך. כן, זה לא.
כאילו זה מוזר לי שגם בטלוויזיה אנחנו נמשכים ואנחנו כן.
אז תראה, זה מודל נכון, אני תמיד בעניין של ז'אנר.
השאלה כמה רחוק אתה הולך נכון? מודל סופר מודל הוא מודל בסין.
זה נשמע אולי השם כאילו השם הנפוץ בישראל, אבל זה בהחלט המשיך.
לא בכדי אתה לא חייב לפעמים. לא אחרי שאתה אומר יש לך.
אתה מניח שהפרמטרים של מדינת ישראל אוקיי, שבה יש פרמטרים ואז אתה מניח שאתה צריך להניח.
אז אתה בטוח, אתה זוכר, אבל בדרך כלל אני 271.
זה בסדר אחר כן. אז אולי אתה לא אוהב ללמוד?
כן. אז טוב, אתה עושה מה אתה עושה? יש כאלה טובים. כן, זה שאתה יכול גם בזמנם, פשוט על ידי רעיונות כאלה של כאילו אני פועל נכון.
כאילו אתה אומר באיזשהו שלב הוא פשוט הולך להניח שיש לו איזשהו פתרון.
אתה מניח שהוא פה. זה בדרך כלל מה שבעצם יכול לעשות.
אני רוצה להימנע מזה, אבל מתוך איזושהי הנחה.
כן, אבל אתה. מה באמת יש?
עכשיו כל מה שדרוש לנו זהו. כי לא ראינו עולם בגודל הזה, לא מצליח להשיג, אבל רוב הנוכחות.
אני יכול להיות שעדיין היה אפשר להגיש כתב אישום וזה לא כאילו לקח שנה של 20.
שנים. מסכים איתך. כל כך חבל שאין להם קצת עבודה בעיניים.
אני יכולה לומר זכיתי במקום הראשון דבש.
למה? לא לא. לא.
סגירת. זה?
נניח. לא.
אוקיי. בסדר.
ועכשיו נציג את המודל. אגודת הסטודנטים.
אז דבר ראשון מוטציה שנמצאת בשימוש נרחב פשוט קצת מקלה על.
חקירה לפעמים על חיים. כתיבת מודלים כאלה זה מה שנקרא בלוק 29.
אוקיי, אז מה הרעיון בבלוק תשע? אז אם אתם כפי שאתם מכירים פיצ'רים ככלל?
הם בעצם איזשהם תכוניות שהם מה שנקרא Observatory,
כלומר שהם איזשהם תכוניות שאני יכול בהינתן איזשהו Sample למדוד אותם ולפיהם בעצם להכריע מה הוא הלייבל הסביר ביותר.
אבל מה שעושים לפעמים זה בעצם מרחיבים את פונקציית הפיצ'רים, כך שהיא תקבל גם את הלייבל.
אוקיי, או לייבל פוטנציאלי בעצם, ומה הדרך הסטנדרטית לעשות את זה?
זה מה שנקרא בלוק מתיישן. כלומר, אם נגיד הפיצ'רים שלי סתם דוגמה פשוטה כן, זה אחד אפס אחד אפס.
אוקיי, יש לי ארבעה פיצ'רים, זה אחד, אפס אחד אפס. אני יכול להגדיר את פונקציית הפיצ'רים שלי, להיות כזאת שמקבלת גם את כאילו עבור האיקס הספציפי הזה.
מה זה אחד אפס אחד אפס? אני יכול להגדיר את פונקציית הפיצ'רים שלי שתקבל בנוסף לאיקס גם לייבל פוטנציאלי,
ובעצם תשים את הווקטור הזה בבלוק בעצם שמתאים ללייבל וכל השאר תכניס אפסים.
כלומר, אם יש לי שלושה לייבל אז עכשיו הפיצ'ר וקטור שלי לא יהיה באורך ארבע.
נגיד זה מה שהוא היה קודם אלא יהיה באורך 12 אבל כל פעם רק לפי בעצם הלייבל הפוטנציאלי שאני מכניס אני אני בעצם רק הבלוק הרלוונטי לאותו הלייבל נדלק.
אוקיי, אנחנו תכף נראה למה זה למה זה לפעמים שימושי. זה מוטציה מאוד מקובלת.
אז בעצם איכשהו הרעיון הוא שבמקום שם כן,
במקום שפונקציית הפיצ'רים תקבל רק את איקס ותחזיר וקטור באורך ארבע יחשב מקבלת גם את איקס וגם את
Y ומחזירה וקטור באורך ארבע כפול שלוש שיש לו רק בלוק אחד שהוא לא אפס ובו באמת נמצאים הפיצ'רים.
בסדר. למה זה טוב? בגלל שהרבה פעמים אנחנו רוצים לדבר על וקטור משקולות ולא על וקטורי משקולות, כן?
אז אם תחשבו על זה, נגיד שאני רוצה לתת איזשהו סקור מעל, ללמוד איזשהו סקור Function בינארי על פני הפיצ'ר.
אוקיי, אז בעצם כך שאני אוכל באמצעות המשקולות האלה להכריע איזה פיצ'ר הוא יותר אינדיקטור
או יותר קונטרה אינדיקציה לגבי זה שהאינסטינקט יהיה שייך לכן לאותו הלייבל.
אז יש לי בעצם שתי דרכים שקולות לעשות את זה.
אחד מהם זה לקחת לחשב את הפיצ'ר וקטור של X ללמוד וקטור משקולות עבור sports.
עוד אחד אחר עבור פוליטיקס, עוד אחד אחר, עבור עבור.
נכון, כל אחד וקטורי המשקולות האלה לקחת אותו, להכפיל אותו בפיצ'ר וקטור כן או וקטור משקולות של ספורט, להכפיל בפיצ'ר וקטור,
לקבל מספר, לקחת את זה של פוליטיקס וקטור, לקבל מספר גרסה של עבר, להכפיל אותה, לקבל מספר ולא פעמיים מספרים יותר גדול.
דרך שקולה לעשות את זה זה בעצם לקחת את הפיצ'ר function שיקבל גם את X וגם את Y.
עכשיו יש לי פיצ'ר וקטור שהוא פשוט מין שרשור של כל וקטורי המשקולות האלה.
אז עכשיו יש לי וקטור אחד של משקולות, רק שהוא פשוט שרשור של הווקטורים שדיברנו עליהם קודם.
ועכשיו מה זה אומר לחשב את Score של איקס ביחס לאיזשהו לאיזושהי מחלקה פוטנציאלית?
ואיך זה איזשהו לייבל פוטנציאלי? זה פשוט אומר לעשות מכפלה סקלרית בין C לבין טאב.
כן, זה לא איזושהי חוכמה גדולה, אבל זה פשוט. זה מוטציה מאוד מקובלת ולכן אני מציג אותה כדי שנשתמש בפרדוקס כדי חישובים בדיוק אותו דבר.
כן, זה סתם עניין של נתצ. בסדר.
אז זה? האם זה פיצ'ר כאילו לא קבוצה אי שם?
ועכשיו איך מוגדר הלא קליני אמרנו? לא מעניין מה מוגדר בצורה הבאה.
הוא בעצם אומר יש לי עכשיו וקטור פיצ'רים.
פי כן הוא מקבל איקס. ווואי פוטנציאלי מחזיר איזשהו וקטור.
כן איזשהו וקטור בבלוק שכל פעם שיחליף את Y זה יהיה בלוק אחר.
אני אקפל אותו בדבליו ועכשיו דבליו כפול פי של X.
וואי זה פשוט אזכור נכון. אזכור של בעצם אני מפרש אותו כסקורר של של וואי.
עבור איקס עם וקטור משקולות Double. אוקיי, ואז אני מקבל איזשהו סקור חיובי או שלילי.
אני מעלה אותו ב האקספוננט כי אני רוצה שיהיה לי מספרים השליליים ואני מלמד אותו.
או במילים אחרות אני מפעיל עליו לסחור עם האלה. בסוף בדיוק.
אני פשוט מפיל עליהם. סופת מטס זה היה קודם, אבל עקב הקופונים היום קוראים לזה סוף מקס ומה שאני מקבל זה פשוט אוסף של מספרים שהם חיוביים ומסתכמים לך.
אוקיי, אז בעצם המודל הזה? המודל הזה הוא מודל.
גנרי עד הסכם נתיבי. סליחה, מאוד פשוט, ומסתבר שהוא יחסית טוב לרן פיצ'רים שיש ביניהם הרבה מאוד תלויות.
הוא בוודאי לא מניח.
התלות מותנה בין הפיצ'רים השונים כמו נייר בייס, ומסתבר שגם באופן פרקטי הוא אותו לרדת יחסית לליברלים, שיש ביניהם קורלציה שיש ביניהם קורלציה יחסית גבוהה.
אוקיי, אז היינו המודל הזה. נתקלתם בו בעבר? אולי בשם אחר?
איך אתם קראתם לו? אוקיי, גם לא רק במקרה בינארי קראתם ברגרסיה גם במקרה לינארי כן.
אוקיי, סבבה, אז זאת סיסטיק קונקשן, למרות שהיא לא ממש מודל רגרסיה.
כפי שאתם יודעים, מודל קלאסי, פיקציה. אבל בסדר. אני אוהב את השם לוקליר מודל, כי סך הכל זה די אינטואיטיבי.
נכון יותר מזה, מודל לינארי נכון מרמז שהקשר בין הלייבלים בין הפיצ'רים לבין הסקורר הוא לינארי.
כן, פשוט כל פיצ'ר מוכפל באיזה שהוא משקל ומתקבל מתקבלת פונקציה לינארית.
אבל ההסתברות עצמה היא כמובן לא לינארית אלא היא לוג לינארית, כלומר האקספוננט של כן.
זה לא אומר. תראה אותו דבר.
זה יהיה נכון, זה אותו דבר. עזוב, זה עניין של מוטציה.
הסיבה שאני משתמש במוטציה הזאת. נראה לי אתם תבינו אותה. בעיקר בשיעור הבא שמתעסק במודלים יותר מורכבים ואז יהיה.
לא יהיה כל כך נוח לדבר על על סט משונה כזה של אה, של של וקטורי משקולות.
יהיה לנו נוח לדבר על וקטור משקולות יחיד ופשוט feature וקטור שאתה יודע כל פעם בוחר את איזה חלק הוא רלוונטי בעצם זה זה זה זה כל הרעיון.
זה נתון אופציה יפה. עזוב לנייר model איך?
ושוב אני מאוד אשמח לפידבק לגבי זה. דברים שאתם ראיתם לא ראיתם?
אני יודע שהדברים גם משתנים משנה לשנה, אז זה גם תלוי באיזה שנה למדתם את הקורסים אופנים למידה.
גם כאן הדרך הסטנדרטית היא לבצע מקסימום לאיטיות.
אז אתם כן. הרבה פעמים לא עובדים עם בלייק לימוד, אלא אם התכוננתי שנה לא הייתי יודע.
לא עובדים עם לוג Like ניגוד נכון כי קל לעבוד יותר עם סכומים מאשר עם מכפלות כי גוזרים.
אבל זה לא משנה אם לא בפונקציה מונוטונית אז אנחנו יכולים להסתכל על הלייק לעוד או למעשה על הלוג של הלייק.
לימוד של training data בתלות ב דאבליו, וקטור משקולות, וקטור המשקולות או בעצם הפרמטרים של המודל.
נכון, אלה הפרמטרים שיש. כל השאר זה פשוט חלק מהמבנה של המודל.
אז Low זה low של הלייק ליהוד? את זה אני יכול להפוך את להוציא את את המכפלה כסכום החוצה, לקבל סכום של הלוגים של ההסתברויות של הגולד לייבל.
בהינתן Training Example עבור דבליו, ואני מנסה למצוא במקסימום להקריב את הישן כמובן את הדאבל יושב ממקסם או את אחד מהדברים שמבקשים מתאר של טאפ.
אוקיי, אבל יש לי ממש צורה מפורשת נכון, באיזושהי צורה מסויימת לאיך נראה פישר מיי בהינתן X נכון,
זה אותו מבנה לוג לינארי ואני יכול להציב אותו בנוסחה ולקבל שני גורמים.
כן, גורם אחד הוא בעצם הלוג של המונה מינוס הלוג של המחנה.
כן, הלוג של המונה הוא פשוט יהיה סקור.
תכף אני אדבר על מה שמתחת, אבל הלוגו של המונה פשוט יהיה score נכון?
מה? למה score דאבליו כפול פי score של הלייבל?
להערכתי בעצם נכון כי Wii פה ממש הכל סטנדרט לייבל פליי קלאוד מינוס הלוג של גורם אנדמול שלפעמים קוראים לו Partition Function.
אולי שמעתם אותו בשם הזה, או איך אתם בדרך כלל קראתם לו בעבר או שלא קראתי?
אוקיי, בסדר גורם, אני ארמון בסדר מינוס לוג של נירמול וזה מה שצריך לגזור.
עכשיו אני דווקא רוצה להתחיל מהתוצאה. כן, מה שאנחנו, מה שאנחנו גם תכף נראה.
איך מגיעים לזה? סך הכל זה די פשוט מה שאנחנו נראה שבעצם אין ביטוי אנליטי, לפחות לא מוכר ביטוי אנליטי.
לכן איך נראה דאבליו שם ממקסם את זה?
אבל הבעיה הזאת היא בעיה כעורה, לפחות כעורה, חלש תחת תנאים מדי רחבים, אפילו כעורה ממש.
ויש לה לכם דאבליו יחיד שמקדם אותה תחת תנאים רחבים וניתן למצוא אותו באמצעות שיטות של אופטימיזציה קמורה.
כן, למשל שיטת מבוססת גרדיאנט. כן, שאתם למדתם.
מישהו כאן לא למד על שיטות אופטימיזציה מבוססות גרדיאנט. עדיין חסם את כל בני הדודים שלו, או לפחות חלקם.
יש הרבה בני דודים. אוקיי, בסדר, אז אנחנו רוצים להשתמש בשיטה מבוססת גרדיאנט.
כאן אפילו זה מוצדק כי יש אופטימלי, גלובלי ואנחנו רוצים לכן לחשב את הגרדיאנט.
איך נראה הגרדיאנט של של הלוג ריילי עוד יש לו צורה קצת אינטואיטיבית.
אוקיי, איך היא? איך היא בעצם נראית? אנחנו אומרים כך הגרדיאנט או כאן הנגזרת החלקית.
כן, זה פשוט קואורדינציה אחת מסוימת שמתחתיה כן, באותה מידה אתם יכולים לכתוב את אותו דבר גם כן.
בוא נכתוב את זה על הלוח. כן, בצורה שקולה כי גרדיאנט.
אז כי גרדיאנט זה יראה כך. הגרדיאנט של אל דבליו שווה לסכום התנאי יפה עם Instant אז.
של Feed, כלומר של הפיצ'ר vector.
עכשיו רק שזה יהיה הפיצ'ר וקטור ולא הקואורדינטות הג'י.
אם אני גוזר לפי הקואורדינטות החלקית בפיצ'ר וקטור.
לפי המשתנה ג'י אני אקבל שם את פי של ג'ק.
אבל אם אני. גוזר באופן כללי, כלומר מסתכל על כל הווקטור אז זה פשוט יהיה הווקטור של כל C.
כן? אז field של x i why i, כלומר הפיצ'ר וקטור של האיקס.
אם מה Wii הלייבל איזה מהם?
כאילו הנכון זה מה שהתכוונו. לא סתם מה שאני חוזה או סתם משהו שנכנסתי זה או הY נכון נכון הפיצ'ר וקטור של הY נכון מינוס סכום על פני כל הY האפשריים.
ההסתברות שהמודל נותן כן לאותו וואי אפשרי עבור x, y כפול.
כן, כאן יש לנו שוב את פי של כתב את הגרדיאנט הכללי, את זה בלי הג'יי פי של איקס.
איי. עכשיו בוא נסתכל מה הנוסחה.
זאת אומרת, היא אומרת משהו מעניין, כאילו יש לו איזושהי קונוטציה קצת אינטואיטיבית.
אתה מכיר? ראיתם את זה? לא. אוקיי, חשבתי שזה יעבוד.
כאילו מה? זה לא מרחק שלנו מהאמת?
בדיוק. זה סוג של בדיוק מה שבעצם יוצא. זה סוג של בעצם שגיאה בפיצ'ר תשע.
כן? אז בעצם איך מה? צורה אינטואיטיבית להבין זה שוב.
אם אתם לא אוהבים את האינטואיציה הזאת, הם פשוט יכולים תכף לראות איך נראית הגזירה.
אבל נראה לי שיש כאן משהו נחמד. אנחנו אומרים אוקיי, לאיזה כיוון אני רוצה להזיז את וקטור המשקולות?
כן. מה? מהו הצורה האופטימלית שבה אני עכשיו אעשה צעד של וקטור המשקולות?
אז כך אני רוצה לעשות צעד בכיוון שהוא פרופורציוני לבסדר על כל דוגמאות האימון.
אבל בוא נגיד שאנחנו עושים. נסתכל כרגע על הגרסה השטוחה.
אוקיי, שאני מגריל שהיא דוגמת אימון ואעשה את הצעד שם.
כן, סטוקס אקראית עם DSL. אני גם מניח שכולם כן.
יש כאן מישהו שלא מכיר את הנושא. אוקיי, נכון, זה ממש הבסיס של האימייל בימינו.
אוקיי, אז בוא אפילו להסתכל רק על הביטוי בתוך הסוגריים, כי הביטוי בחוץ זה פשוט הופך את זה מגרסה שטוחה סטטית, לגרסה לא שטוחה, סטטית או להפך.
אז בעצם אני אומר העידכון שלי בעקבות הדוגמה בעקבות הדוגמה AI היא נכנסתי ועכשיו הבית שלי הוא הדוגמה I נגיד.
אז מה אני עושה? אני לוקח את הפיצ'ר Present Teacher של אותו איקס.
איי אם הY היה נכון? אוקיי, כלומר אני לוקח את וקטור הפיצ'רים.
אוקיי, ואני אומר אני אומר ככה אם נתתי הסתברות בסדר זה לא ידע.
ממש אפס. אבל הסתברות כמעט אפס ללייבל הנכון.
אוקיי, כלומר ההתפלגות דאבליו הנוכחי שלי כן, המקום שאני כרגע עומד בו.
כן, ההתפלגות שאותו דאבליו משרה הלוויין היא ממש על הפנים, על הפנים היא נותנת הסתברות דה פקטו אפס ללייבל הנכון.
בסדר במקרה הזה. מעניין מה אני צריך לעשות במקרה הזה.
מה שאני צריך לעשות זה בוא נגיד שהיא נותנת ללייבל אחר הסתברות כמעט אחד.
אוקיי, זאת אומרת, היא גם טועה בלייבל הנכון, והיא גם נותנת את כל מסת ההסתברות לאחד אחר וזה קו מדידת אחר.
אוקיי, אז במקרה כאן התוחלת הזאת על פני כל הפסים בהתאם לווייט תג תהיה בערך מה?
כן תשימו לב זה תוחלת הסכימה על כל לווייתן. ההסתברות של לווייתן בהינתן X כפול הפיצ'ר וקטור עם אותו הוא הייתה.
כן, זה בעצם לפעמים כותבים את זה. התוחלת מוכלת של.
X איי וואי טאג אם וואי תג נדגם לפי P של וואי ת בהינתן x.
אוקיי. בסדר, אתם רואים?
זה פשוט תוחלת. כן. אז אוקיי, אז בוא נניח שעכשיו אני בטאבלט.
הוא ממש גרוע. איזה סוג של גרוע גרוע שהוא נותן ללייבל אחר את כל מסת ההסתברות ולמכון או לא משאיר או לא משאיר כלום.
בסדר כמעט כלום. זרם כאן ממש אפסים. אבל בוא נגיד משהו זניח.
אז מה התוחלת הזאת שווה? רגע, מה?
הנכון? ובכן, בדיוק הגורם הזה הוא אפס.
זאת אומרת הקופי של הפין נכון הוא אפס, על כן נשאר מתוך כל הסכימה הזאת.
הפיצ'ר הווקטור של הלא נכון נכון? בעצם. אז מה שאנחנו מקבלים כאן זה פיצ'ר וקטור של איקס איי אם איזשהו Y לא קשור בסדר.
וכאן אנחנו מקבלים את הפיצ'ר וקטור של הוואי הנכון, אז אנחנו מקבלים שהעדכון הוא כן הפיצ'ר וקטור של הנכון פחות.
הפיצ'ר וקטור של מה שאתה חושב שהוא הנכון אבל הוא בכלל אוקיי, כנל.
אגב, גם אם המודל שלי לגמרי צודק. כן, אם המודל שלי לגמרי צודק עדיין.
כלומר הוא נותן הסתברות כמעט 1 ל y, כלומר לווי האמיתי נכון, ובמקרה אז מתוך התוחלת הזאת יישאר בערך פי של איקס wii והשינוי שלי יהיה בערך.
אפס, נכון? זה פשוט מה שחזי.
מה שאני, מה שהוא הנכון פחות. מה שאני חושב שהוא הנכון.
מה שאני חושב שהוא הנכון כבר נכון. אז אני לא צריך לעדכן.
אני לא חושב שהוא הנכון, אז אני צריך לעשות מין צעד פרסה פתרון כזה.
מי שמכיר את האלגוריתם זה בעצם מאוד קשור לזה איכשהו.
כן, מי שלא מכיר את האלגוריתם גם בסדר. נדבר עליו קצת בהמשך הקורס, אבל באופן עקרוני מה שהדבר הזה עושה זה סוג של אתם יכולים לחשוב הערכה לשגיאה.
כן, בעצם אני אומר אני עכשיו הולך להתקדם בכיוון הפיצ'רים.
פרזנטי שם נכון, מינוס מה שאני עכשיו חושב שהוא הפיצ'ר הזה.
תשע נכון? בצורה כן, בעצם זה לא אחד.
זה אולי כמה, כי אני מחלק את ההסתברות שלי מכמה לייבלים, אז אני עושה תוכן הפיצ'ר פקטורים שאני חושב שהם נכונים.
שאלות לגבי זה? אוקיי, איך?
למה בעצם זה מה שיוצא? אז בעצם זה לא קשה לקבל את זה?
אז אוקיי, אז Low כאמור אמרנו זה סכום על הלוגים של הטון.
הגזמה פלוס. כן לוקח את הלוק של המונה.
אני פשוט מקבל את score דאבליו כפול פי הפורקן.
דו אלים כפול פי כן, זה הלוג של המונה מינוס הלוג של גורם נרמול שלפעמים קוראים לו Partition.
יפה עכשיו אם אני גוזר את זה, נגיד אני לוקח את המגזר קואורדינציה הגיד של הגרדיאנט.
הנגזרת החלקית הג'יי אז דבליו כפול פי.
מה שנשאר לי כאן זה בעצם מתוך המכפלה סקלרית הזאת.
יש לי הרבה אפסים מלבד במקום שמופיע דאבליו ג'יי שאז הנגזרת היא פשוט המקדם של דאבליו שזה פי ג'יי איקס Y.
כן, זה בעצם הכוונה. היא כאן איקס IUI.
סליחה, כן צריך להוסיף. הכוונה היא זה הנכונים.
כן, מינוס הנגזרת של הדבר הזה.
אוקיי, מה הנגזרת של הדבר הזה? נגזרת של לוג של פונקציה זה.
כן, אחד חלקי. הפונקציה כפולה. הנגזרת הפנימית נכון, אז אחד חלקי גורם לנרמול כפול הנגזרת הפנימית.
מה זאת הנגזרת הפנימית? אז כזכור לכם האקספוננט נכון, כשזה גוזרים את פונט זה בעצם הוא עצמו כפול הנגזרת הפנימית.
אז הנה הוא עצמו כן, עד כדי זה ששיניתי את זה.
האירוע יתקיים לא משנה כלום וכפול הנגזרת הפנימית של דאבליו ג'יי שזה פשוט שוב המקדם של דברים ג'יי, כלומר פי.
ג'יי של איקס בעצם איקס I מה שנקרא דאבל יו.
אס חוויית הגאים. עכשיו אני יכול להכניס את הגורם הזה פנימה לתוך הסוגריים.
אז אני מקבל את הביטוי שכתוב כאן, ואם אני נזכר אז אני באיך נראה Play בהינתן איקס או פי שווי תגים.
בהינתן איקס במקרה כאן, אז אני שם לב שהביטוי הזה הוא פשוט פישר.
וואט דה גיים בהינתן איקס? ואם אני כותב את זה בצורה וקטורית אז אני מקבל בדיוק את מה שכתוב כאן.
אוקיי, אז סך הכל דרישת סימון פשוטה וכן ואמרה שיש כאן איזשהו קשר מעניין גם לאלגוריתמים אחרים כמו פה.
כן. אוי ואבוי, זה סתם עניין.
הרי זה משתנה כבול. כן, אז הוא עובר על פני כל הלייבלים.
אני חושב שהשתמשתי כאן ב white תגים סתם כדי שכאילו כי אתה רואה כי גם כאן יש ווינטג בעצם.
אז כאילו לא רציתי שיהיה פה סכימה על וואי טאג ואז זה עדיין היה נכון, אבל זה היה מין סקופ כזה.
אתה יודע, לא נעים. אז בקיצור עדיף לכתוב את אורטגה.
עוד שאלות. אוקיי. בסדר.
יפה. אבל כפי שאתם זוכרים, כשאנחנו מפעילים מודלים, דיסקים, נרטיבים כפי שאתם זוכרים.
למשל בהקשר של רשתות נוירונים. אבל אותו דבר גם כאן בלוגיסטיקה, גשם ולא גלי ניר מודלס.
אנחנו הרבה פעמים רוצים להכניס איזשהו גורם רגולרי. זה עצים נכון?
למה אנחנו רוצים להכניס גורם רגולרי? זה הצגה? מישהו זוכר?
שזה לא יהיה, שזה לא יעבוד. אוקיי.
כלומר, מה החשש שלנו כאן אם אמרנו?
החשש שלנו במודלים הנרטיבים נכון היה שיהיה לנו כל מיני אפסים או דברים מאוד קרובים לאפס, אבל כן, אין דברים כאלה כאן על פניו.
א. נפשי כן, זה בטוח. כאילו לא יהיו הסתברויות אפס כי פשוט.
זה לא יודע לתת הסתברויות אפס. אבל אתה צודק. עדיין יש פוטנציאל לאובר פיטים.
איך נראה פה? זה כבר לא נראה כמו משכורת אפס, נכון?
כי זה לא. אז איך הוא נקרא? שיהיה בן.
כן. אוקיי, נכון, אז העניין של נועם. שאנחנו איכשהו רוצים לשלוט בה?
כן, במשקלים בעצם שאנחנו מייחסים לפיצ'ר עם השנים. למה?
אז בוא נראה דוגמה. מה אתם יודעים מה קודם לכתוב את הנוסחה?
שאתם מכירים? כן.
אז מה שאני יכול לעשות זה יחסית בקלות להוסיף עוד גורם נרמול הגורמים נירמול הכי סטנדרטי
שמשתמשים בו זה גורם נרמול של מה שנקרא לפעמים watch נכון או H2 או דולרי זה ישן.
כל הדברים האלה הם אותו דבר שהם בעצם פשוט הנורמה של משהו שהוא פרופורציוני עם איזשהו היתר.
פרמטר לנורמה של הפיצ'ר פקטור בריבוע.
כן. אז מישהו או מישהי כאן לא מכירים את החומר הזה?
אוקיי. זה משהו סטנדרטי שנלמד עכשיו למה שכל כך יעניין.
אז בעצם מה זה אומר? זה אומר שאנחנו איכשהו רוצים להגיד, להקל, להגיד כן לבעיית האופטימיזציה?
כן, תנסי למקסם את ההסתברות של הווים הנכונים.
זה שעסקו solution על האיקסים כן, כמה שיותר זה ידחוף לשם.
אבל אם עשית את זה במחיר של דאבל הוא גדול מדי בנורמה.
כלומר. משקולות גדולים מדי, אז צריך איכשהו לאזן בין הדבר.
אוקיי, כלומר מקבלים עונש על משקולות גדול.
ובעצם כן בעיית אופטימיזציה משתנה בצורה מאוד קלה.
נכון, כי הנגזרת בעצם הגרדיאנט של נורמה בריבוע זה פשוט דאבליו עצמו נכון?
או אם כפול מקדם משהו שהוא פרופורציונלי דאבליו ובגלל זה זה גם קוראים לזה Watch.
אז כל הדברים האלה אתם מכירים. פשוט מה שעושים זה מכניסים איזשהו גורם.
במקרה כאן אנחנו ערים, הם מקסימים את עליית ליבות ואני מניח שאתם בדרך כלל.
ראיתם מישהו תוהה למה זה פלוס מינוס או כאלה, נכון?
הרי אני מניח שבאי מייל וכאלה לומדים שיש לכם לא Function ואתם מנסים למזער אותה וכאן זה מאוד דומה לזה.
רק שיש לכם likely עוד function ואתם מנסים למקסם אותה.
אוקיי אז זה כאילו פשוט ההפך עם שם.
אם אתם מנסים למקסם אז אתם מוסיפים את הריגוש.
אריזה צפייה עם מינוס שלילי ואם אתם רוצים למזער אז אתם מוסיפים גורם הקולוניזציה חיובי.
כן, ואפשר כמובן לשנות את ה [INAUDIBLE] בהתאם.
אוקיי, אז איך זה? אז בוא נראה דוגמה אמיתית להבין איך זה באמת יכול לקרות, מה באמת קורה ואיך זה נראה.
אז אוקיי, אז נגיד שאנחנו רוצים לעסוק בבעיה. בעיה קלאסית בין על פי מה שנקרא named entity הגמישה.
אוקיי, מה הכוונה? אנחנו רוצים לזהות שמות ולתת להם קטגוריות.
מה הכוונה לזהות שם? וזה עוד שם. אנחנו מניחים שזה מין משהו לא מקונן כן, לא מסד.
כלומר זה פשוט לשים סוגריים לא חופפים סביב חלק מהמילים ולהגיד מכאן עד כאן זה שם ולהגיד מעלי בלשון איזה סוג טיפוס של מישהו יותר.
אז הדוגמה סייטן. האפיון פרייסלס. יונייטד איירליינס פרייד ספייס איקס, דונלד טראמפ הייתה טה טה טה טה טה זה האסכולה solution.
אוקיי, אז אנחנו אתם רואים שיש שם עם סוגריים עם כאלה נכון אנחנו אומרים יונייטד איירליינס זה שם אחד, זה לא שתי שמות, זה דבר אחד והוא מסוג אורגני,
זה השם, ואמריקן איירליינס הוא גם מסוג אורגני, זה השם וטים וואגנר שם הוא מסוג Person וסקס Dollars הוא מסוג מאני וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, ולפעמים יש להם מילה אחת לפעמים יש להם כמה מילים, כמה טוב, כן, בסדר, אבל אנחנו מניחים שהם לא חופפים והם לא מכוננים אחד את השני.
לפחות בגרסה הקלאסית אין את התרגום משם.
ואנחנו רוצים לפתור את הבעיה הזאת. טוב, אז אנחנו קצת נלמד בהמשך בדיוק איך פותרים אותה.
אבל בוא אפילו נניח שכבר שמו לנו את הסוגריים, אם כן, ואנחנו רק רוצים לדעת מה ליבר.
זאת אומרת אני מסתכל עכשיו על תת בעיה שבה כבר יש לי איזשהו name.
דלת התא כבר יש לי שם, ואני רוצה לדעת האם מדובר למשל וכן location או person בסדר לדוגמה.
אז עכשיו אוקיי, אז אני מסתכל כאן בכל זאת רגולרי זה ישן.
סליחה אפרידר שמאל זה כן. אוקיי, זה את.
נגיד שאני עכשיו רוצה להסתכל באמת על למשל המילה הזאת.
גרייס כן ולזהות מה הפרדס מה?
סליחה? למה היא שייכת?
כן. האם זה חלק מיי לוקיישן או חלק מפס? כן או אולי קטגוריה אחר?
אז למשל, אני יכול לחשוב על כל מיני לייבלים רלוונטים.
נגיד למשל המילה עצמה Grace. כן, היא אולי מסייעת לי לדעת אם זה פרסם או זה ישנה.
אני יכול גם להסתכל נגיד רק על האות הראשונה שהיא מתחילה ב או על שתי האותיות הראשונות,
או אני יכול להסתכל על כמה מילים נכון, כאילו נגיד להסתכל על המילה הזאת כולל והמילה שבאה אחריה bigger או tribe וכן הלאה.
אני יכול להסתכל כמו הרבה פיצ'רים שפשוט קשורים למילה או חתיכות של המילה או המילה, יחד עם עוד מילים קרובות.
אוקיי, וכל אחד מהפיצ'רים האלה עשוי להיות אינפורמטיבית.
עכשיו יש לי כאן קצת trade off. נכון? כי אני אופקי.
מה זה? מה יותר טובה מילה ומה יותר טוב?
פיצ'ר שנגיד מקודד פשוט אותיות או זוגות אותיות לעומת פיצ'ר שמקודד מילים שלמות או זוגות של מילים.
ואם כן אז עכשיו אנחנו מסתכלים על זה.
כן הבנתם? אנחנו צריכים מרחב פיצ'רים שמכיל מי מילים,
מי הם האותיות שמרכיבות אותו זוגות האותיות או שלושת האותיות עד ממש לזהות המילה השלמה או המילה השלמה יחד עם עוד מילים שלפניה ואחריה.
כאילו אז יש לי פה איזה טווח, כן?
מה יותר טוב בצד הזה של הטווח? מה יותר טוב בצד הזה של טווח?
כן, כאילו למילים כנראה שתהיה יותר משמעות.
יש לנו פחות אפשרויות. אז אולי זה מקטין את כמות האפשרויות שזר לך למספר שנים?
כן, נכון. אז נכון, אז באמת למילה יש.
בוא נאמר ככה אם אני עכשיו אומר לכם יש לי מילה שמתחילה למשל בג'יי אר.
כן, אז אולי אתם לא תדעו אם זה גרייס השם או טוב במקרה הזה זה מין אולי גרייס שהוא לוקיישן,
אבל נגיד למשל גרג, שהוא השם נכון, או גרייס שהוא מדינה או לא יודע מה.
כן, זה ייתן לכם מידע מסוים. אולי עדיין יש שם איזשהו טרנד סטטיסטי, לא אומר לפסול את הפיצ'ר הזה, אבל זה פיצ'ר אולי יחסית חלש מהבחינה של כמה הוא פיקטיבי.
לגבי הלייבל, מהו הלייבל הנכון, לעומת זאת, לא יודע מד דמוקרטי.
אני לא יודע מה השם המלא של יוון Public או גרייס או משהו כזה.
כן, זה בפני עצמו. גם יכול להיות פיצ'ר נכון?
האם מופיע שם The Republic? או האם אני עכשיו מסתכל על על מילה שהיא חלק מהביטוי The Public of גריס?
ואם דר יפה וכו. גריס מופיע כבר אין יותר מדי התלבטויות, זה די בטוח.
אוקיי, שמה זה עוד יכול להיות. זה לא נשמע כמו שם של מישהו, אז זה טוב מהבחינה הזאת, אבל מצד שני Feature הזה כנראה הוא יהיה הרבה יותר space.
נכון public אוף גריס. כמה פעמים כבר מופיע דרייבר בגוף?
כריס כנראה הרבה פחות פעמים מי שהופיע גרייס או שהופיע GR או שהופיע ג'י בסדר, אז בגדול זה פשוט אקספרסיביות כמו הספר City.
כן, עוד סוג של בעיה. סברין סטרידו נכון זה ואנחנו רוצים רגולרי סדציה.
למה אנחנו רוצים רגולרי? זה הפציעה. בוא נחשוב על זה. מה אם אין לי רגולרי?
זה ציה? מה עשוי לקרות? כאילו אם אני רגולרית זזתי אז איכשהו אני לא נענש.
על מה? זה מסובך? כן.
מי אמר? כן, נכון, המודל מסובך. כלומר על מה כן בדיוק?
זאת אומרת יכול להיות שנגיד יש לי דוגמה אחת. שמופיע שם The Republic of Grace שם זה באמת לוקיישן.
ואני אומר אוקיי, מה שאני לומד מכאן זה הפיצ'ר הזה.
הוא פיצ'ר מנצח. צריך לתת לו wait נורא נורא גדול וזהו.
נהדר. רק הבעיה עם זה עשויה להיות שהוא לא מחליף טוב.
נכון, זה לא מחליף טוב, זה יפה ואם אתם עושים רגולרי זה הצגה.
אז נגיד כן. הדיאגרמה הזאת כן מראה שלמרות שאולי היינו מצפים שכריס יהיה פיצ'ר יותר אינדי כתיבה מאשר כלומר יקבל wait משמעותית יותר גדול מאשר VR.
נגיד כאן יצא להם עם איזה שיר רגולרי זה היה שהם הכניסו שדווקא הG4 קיבל איזה שהם וויטס משמעותית יותר גדולים למרות שברור שהוא עם big US.
כן, למרות שברור שהוא יותר big US והכל תודות ללגליזציה.
אז זה פחות או יותר הייתה הפואנטה כאן. שאתם כבר מכירים מקורסים קודמים.
אוקיי, עכשיו נעבור לבעיה יותר מעניינת. קצת ככה נתחיל להתחכך עם בעיות קצת יותר אמיתיות.
שזאת בעיית הסנטימנט analysis אוקיי, סיווג סנטימנט של טקסט ואנחנו נסביר מה הכוונה.
אז בעצם דוגמה שממנה ממש התחיל התחום, ככה לפחות התחום שלו בגרסתו המודרנית הדי תת לבן זה בעצם ביקורות של סרטים.
אוקיי, ביקורות של סרטים. למה זה נחמד? כי היה להם איזשהו אוסף מאוד גדול של data פוינטס.
זה קוראים לו IMDB. אם אתם מכירים האינטרנט מובי Database היה להם שם.
כן, בעצם הרבה מאוד Reviews שאנשים כתבו בכל אחד מהם.
מה אנשים גם בדרך כלל מזהים? מישהו מכיר את IMDB?
מלבד הטקסט החופשי, כל רביו מכיל כל ציר ציון בדיוק.
הוא מכיל ציון ואז יש לנו training set ואפשר להשתמש בו ומאוד נחמד.
אז באמת שם זה התחיל לפחות העיסוק האקדמי בזה והחדשני, ואז אנחנו רוצים לסווג דברים כמו אן בלי ובלי דיסק פוינט Thing.
נגיד כשלילי פולו זה אני כבר הסנדוויץ שלי.
Apply set אין שום תלות קלוט טוויסט חיובי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
פלסטיק זה שלילי, גרייט אסקובר קומדי חיובי וכולי.
אבל זה כמובן התרחב מאז וכבר לא רק סרטים.
נגיד, למשל, עוד תחום אקלקטי וידוע זה מדפסות, או באופן כללי כל מיני קניות שאתם עושים באינטרנט וגם שם אתם רוצים.
אולי אתם לא רוצים רק להגיד סיווג חיובי שלילי? אולי אתם רוצים משהו יותר מתוחכם שגם מפריד את זה לצירים?
נכון שאתם אומרים אוקיי, נכון, לפי המדפסת הזאת לא,
זה לא רוצה להגיד מי יותר טובה המדפסת הזאת כי זאת יותר קלה לשימוש והיא יותר זולה אבל זאת יותר חדה ולא יודע מה שוקלת פחות.
אין לי מושג. אז אז אפשר גם להפריד את זה לצירים.
אנשים השתמשו בזה כבר הרבה שנים. כן, זה משהו שלקוח ממאמר משנת 2001.
כן, משתמשים בזה בשביל לחזות תנודות יחסית לוקאלית של מניות על סמך הבלוגוספירה.
הסוף של מידע? כן, גם כאן הרעיון הוא די פשוט.
נכון, יש המון מידע שפשוט זמין באופן פתוח.
אם אתם עוקבים אחרי הבלוגים Social Media, כל מיני דברים שמפורסמים בכל מיני מקומות עלומים, יש שם הרבה מידע לגבי הטרנדים.
מה הולך לקרות למניה. הולך לקרות כל מיני מדדים כמו נאסדאק במקרה של כאן.
ואפשר לנצל את זה. כן, אפשר לנצל את זה אולי כדי להרוויח כסף על ידי עסקאות מהירות.
וכמובן אף אחד לא יכול לשבת ולקרוא את הכל.
אבל אם יש לכם סנטימנט analysis, ביחוד אם הוא מספיק מהיר, אולי תצליחו לעשות את זה כמה שברירי שניה לפני המתחרים שלכם ולגרוף קופה.
אוקיי, אז זה בערך הרעיון. ובאמת גם בזה משתמשים די הרבה זמן.
אז אוקיי, אז אז ברור שיש מוטיבציה. כמובן. כיסיתי רק את קצה הקרחון.
פוליטיקאים משתמשים בזה, קמפיינים שיווקיים משתמשים בסנטימנט כל מיני דברים עם הרבה מאוד פעמים.
אנחנו פשוט רוצים להיות מסוגלים לנתח כמות מאוד גדולה של דאטה לגבי מה הם הטרנדים של הסנטימנטים שם,
אבל לפעמים כמויות גם יותר קטנות של דאטה בצורה קצת יותר מדוקדקת ומדויקת.
אז מה זה בכלל סנטימנט? כן, על מה אנחנו מדברים כשאנחנו אומרים על סנטימנט, אומר עסיס.
אז צריך לומר הסנטימנט הוא רק נקודה אחת,
או רק בעצם זווית אחת של מרחב יותר גדול של אפשרויות שמה שנקרא אפקט כן קוראים לזה בפסיכולוגיה או שנקרא אפקטים States כן,
אפקט כאילו הכוונה היא כן כל הדברים שקשורים כנראה לנו יש איזה מילה טובה בעברית,
אבל כאילו הרעיון, דברים שכן קשורים לעמודה, לרגש, לאיזשהו פריט דיספוזיציה לכל מיני דברים כאלה.
ושם אני מחלק את זה לתיאולוגיה נחמדה, הוא אומר כך תראו בהיי level אפשר לחלק את כל הנושא הזה של אפקט לכמה קטגוריות.
היי לב. כן, אחד מהם זה motion. כן, ממש רגש.
כן, במובן הזה, משהו שמה שחשים בכם, שיש לו איזשהו ביטוי גם גופני בדרך כלל סביב איזשהו אירוע שהוא מספיק מעורר כדי לגרום לנו לתגובה כזאת.
כן, אז זה רגש, משהו חי motion מוד זה פשוט המצב הכללי של כן, זה איזשהו מצב שהוא בדרך כלל כן מתמשך, נכון?
הפיוס כן non cost. כלומר אין לו בדרך כלל איזשהו גורם מיידי מובחן.
ברור שאליו הוא מתייחס נכון. אולי אני צ'יף או לגלול מהר את הבול וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי. משהו שהוא אפילו יותר קבוע מזה. זה מה שנקרא personality chat.
נכון, יכול להיות שאני באופן כללי בן אדם מאוד שמח ונוטה לראות את הכל בצורה אופטימית.
כן, ואז אולי אפילו נגיד שזה לא מוד אלא ממש תכונת אישיות שלי.
ויש באמת את הנושאים האלה שאנחנו בעיקר מתעסקים בהם בין P, בייחוד בשני אטיטיוד.
אבל שווה גם להכיר את הדבר הראשון Interface Annual Sciences.
אז הכוונה היא שזה איזשהו אפקטיבי. סטייט ביחס לאיזשהו לרוב ביחס איזשהו בן אדם או סביב איזושהי אינטראקציה מסוימת.
בסדר, אז זה משהו שהוא יותר קשור לתקשורת בין אישית וליחסים בין אנשים והרבה מאוד מההתעסקות בענפי סביב מה שנקרא אטיטיוד.
כן, שרטוט הכוונה היא באופן כללי.
מה היחס שלי כלפי משהו?
כאילו מה דיספוזיציה שלי כלפי איזה דבר מסוים כן ואיך הוא הגדיר את זה?
Anti אפקט בלי קללות, בלי אפס. אוקיי, משהו שיש לו איזשהו חיובי, איזשהו פופולריות כן, חיובי שלילי הוא אם טיורינג הוא בדרך כלל מתמשך.
זה לא פשוט, אה? אוקיי, עכשיו בדיוק חטפתי מכה ברגל, אז כאילו מאוד כואב לי.
אז האטיטיוד שלי השתנה. אולי המצב רוח שלי השתנה או כל מיני דברים השתנו, אבל כנראה לא.
האטיטיוד כן דיספוזיציה Two סיינטס כן דיספוזיציה, כלומר איזושהי נטייה.
כן. אז בטקסטים, כאילו בלי ציניות בהקשר הזה, אנחנו נדבר קצת על ציניות.
כן, ציניות באמת. זה משהו שזה. כן, שאלה.
באמת אחלה נודלס. כן, אוקיי, יפה.
אוקיי, עכשיו רבע לא. וזה נכבה נכבד. ביקשתי מה שלא טוב.
בכל מקרה זמן טוב, אז בדיוק הזמן להפסקה. ביקשתי מהם שהמשיכו את זה תוך כדי ההפסקה, אז נראה אם זה קורה.
אבל בוא באמת עכשיו חורף. על מה זה אומר?
שום דבר. שינו יופי. אוקיי, אז נחזור בשתיים.
כן נכון. עכשיו.
כן. כרגע.
כי זה עניין. מה?
לא. זהו.
זה לא סביר, אבל זה מספיק נכון.
זה ממש. שעדיין לא ראינו. טיבי.
אבל בדרך הנרטיב יהיה בסוף הדרך של.
טקסט. 20.
ואצלך מתורגמת שתי מילים כל פעם באופן.
אז מה יש? נכון לחלק את זה לזוגות שוכבים.
אני לא יודע אם זה. אוקיי, אז השאלה היא חותכת.
אתם מסתכלים על הקשר? כן, אבל לא.
אה, לא. אוקיי. וזה ממש לא. משהו כזה.
מה זה משחק הפוקר הזה? כן. אז. מה זה אומר?
אני לא יודעת. זאת אומרת, זה מוגדר היטב גם. אבל האם זה פותר את השאלה בעצם לנסות לתת פרס?
בכל אופן מאחר שמי. ריח חריף משהו.
נכון. 5.
לא, לא אני. לא, אבל אני לא יכול.
זאת השאלה שלי. לא רוצים שיבוא.
השאלה אם תקחו את המדיניות ואם לא תגידו לא נכון.
זה מה שקרה. לא, לא, זו הייתה תשובה טובה בשבע השנים האחרונות.
אוקיי, שלחתי את המשפחות, לא. בגדול התחושה שלי.
ואני יכול גם לספר את כל זה. מה שזה.
אוקיי, אז בוא נגדיר את זה בצורה קצת יותר מדויקת.
סנטימנט analysis. אז שמתם לב? טניס עוסק בגדול ב אטיטיוד כפי שדיברנו בשיעור הקודם.
ויש לו כל מיני וריאנטים. שהעבריין הפשוט ביותר הוא העבריין של הפוליטי.
כלומר. כלומר לזהות האם טקסט מסוים הוא פוזיטיב נגטיב, לפעמים Nature, לפעמים זה מגיע גם עם איזושהי רמה של Intense.
טי. כן, כמה זה חיובי, כמה זה שלילי ולפעמים זה פשוט בינארי.
אז זה בדרך כלל הדבר הבסיסי ביותר שמכניסים, אבל לפעמים גם מכניסים מימדים נוספים כמו מי מחזיק את התיעוד הזה?
כן, לפעמים הטקסט הוא לא נכתב בגוף ראשון, אלא נכתב על מישהו או מי שהם שמחזיקים באותו באותו סנטימנט כלפי האובייקט הזה,
העודף Target לפעמים זה לא ברור, אז גם כלפי מה מחזיקים?
האם זה מדפסת, מניה, א, מניה ב וכו.
מהו הטקסט? כלומר לעשות איזשהו לוקליזציה של הטקסט, להגיד איפה בתוך כל המסמך הארוך הזה או הפוסט או מה שזה לא יהיה, מופיע אותו הטקסט שבו הוא בא.
אטיטיוד מסוג א כן קזינו.
אז כל אחד מהדברים האלה בעצם יכול להיות איזה שהוא אספקט.
גם לפעמים יש לנו אוסף של טיפוסים שמגדירים כן הערכה, שנאה, חיבה, רצון כזה, Desire וכן הלאה בדרך כלל.
אבל למרות שזה עולם די עשיר, רוב העבודות עוסקות באיזשהו סוג של פוליטי.
אולי, אם כן, חיובי או שלילי, אולי עם משהו קצת יותר, קצת יותר גרדיאנט מאשר בינארי, כמו כוכבים מאחד עד חמש או ציון מאחד עד עשר או מה שזה לא יהיה.
אבל זה בגדול משהו שהוא חד מימדי. יש. עוד איזשהו אספקט שהוא כן יחסית.
יש לו ביטוי רב בספרות. זה איכשהו הרעיון שבמקום לתת איזושהי פרי דיקציה לגבי כל הטקסט, או לחילופין להגיד פרי דיקציה לגבי כל הטקסט וזה מופיע באזור כאן.
אז הרעיון הוא לחלק את הטקסט ל סגמנטים, כמובן סגמנטים שגם בתוכם יש אולי תתי סגמנטים ותתי תתי סגמנטים וכן הלאה, ולכל אחד מהם לתת ערך של סנטימנט.
כן, אז לדוגמה, משפט כמו בפיצה אובר עובד בדתו Top.
הוואפן אוקיי עשוי לקבל תחת משימה כזאת פוזיציה שאומרת אוקיי, הטקסט תמיד הפיצה בסוף את הטקסט בפיצה.
בסוף עובד מביע סנטימנט שלילי כלפי החנות פיצות הזאת זה Top, מסגור פן מביע סנטימנט חיובי והכל ביחד.
כן, כי גם בדרך כלל אנחנו רוצים גם לא רק את החתיכות אלא גם את כן את היחידות הגדולות יותר.
בסך הכל זה מביע סנטימנט שלילי. אוקיי, אז גם כאלה דברים היררכיים יש.
וזה דבר מעניין בדיוק לראות איך טקסטים שהם מביאים כן חתיכות ביניהם מביעות סנטימנט א עשויים בסוף להעביר סנטימנט.
ב. שזה בדיוק מתקשר לעניין הסרקזם. גם שם הסכום יעלה.
כן, שאלת קודם מה שמך אילן בירן עירא?
אוקיי. מאוד יפה.
כן, וזה IMDB שדיברנו עליו מאוד. אז מאיפה מתחילים?
אז דבר ראשון כבעיה של טקסט ללא ספק כן, נגיד יש לכם כך וכך קטגוריות איזשהו מספר סופי קטן, אולי רק 2 של קטגוריה של קטגוריות.
אתם יכולים פשוט להפעיל את אחד מהכלל הספארס אר.
חביבים שדנו בהם מוקדם יותר היום, עם פיצ'רים שכוללים כמעט תמיד את הזהות של המילים עצמם, לפעמים גם אם אין גרמים.
כן, תלוי אם זה המודל, לא גלינארי, שכאמור לא צריך להניח, יש תלות בין הפיצ'רים.
אז אולי זוגות של מילים, שלשות וכן הלאה. הרבה פעמים מארק אפ הוא די חשוב.
כן, כל מיני מה נמצא, מה הכוונה? מה נמצא?
בולט פייס, מה נמצא ב אנדר line? מה כותרת מה?
כותרת משנה מה פונט Not? לא יודע.
כן, כל כל העניינים האלה של מרקו האשטאג וכן הלאה.
אז זה גם מסתבר, להיות משהו חשוב, אבל זה עדיין נכלל בתוך ה framework שבגוף פורץ.
כן, בגדול זה אולי מוסיף על זה עוד איזשהו סיבוך או איזשהו סיבוך קל.
לפעמים גם התדירות של המילים היא משנה במקרה הזה, בגלל שבגלל שהתדירות בדרך כלל לא מניחים שהתדירות משפיעה באופן לינארי.
נגיד תחשבו לא ליניארי כן לא בליני המודל.
אין לו שום בעיה להתמודד עם פיצ'רים לא בינאריים.
כן פיצ'רים רציפים נגיד. אוקיי, אז לכאורה אתם יכולים לקודד לפיצ'ר את מספר ההופעות של מילה מסוימת במסמך.
זה בדרך כלל רעיון לא טוב. כן? למה? אוקיי, אז אתם מבינים מה אני מציע?
מה שאני מציע זה שכל מילה במסמך שמופיע במסמך תקבל feature יחיד, והערך של הפיצ'ר הזה יהיה כמספר ההופעות שלה.
אפס או כמה שיותר. איך אנחנו נעשה את זה?
עדיין אין משמעות לסדר, נכון, אבל אוקיי, נכון, אז זאת בעיה אחת, אבל זה מין באנרים תתבלבלו ועוד שהפעם זה גודל אף.
אבל שוב כן, אנחנו לא עושים. אוקיי, אז נכון, אז לפעמים אולי אנחנו נרצה את זה, אבל אז אולי אנחנו יכולים לקוות שהם יקבלו איזה wait אפס או קרוב.
לפחות אם יש שם data מספיק מהימן. איכשהו הם מצאו על הכל ויקבלו wait מאוד נמוך, אבל הבעיה היא גם שהאפקט הוא לא ליניארי.
זאת הנקודה. כאילו תיזכרו עסקו שלנו ולא בלי נייר.
מודל כן, ממש מעצם שמו score שלנו הוא בעצם לקחת כל פיצ'ר נכון ולכל פיצ'ר ליחס ווייט כן, כלומר עבור ערך אחד אני מקבל טוויט.
אז חמש זה אומר נגיד האינדיקטורים מינוס 5 זה אומר מאוד לא אינדיקטור פי שתיים זה קצת אוביקטיבי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אבל עכשיו בוא נגיד שהפיצה הוא לא אחד או אפס, אלא כל מספר טבעי.
אוקיי, כל מספר טבעי, מה אז יקרה?
אז בעצם באיזושהי צורה? מה שאתם מניחים זה שאם הופעה של מילה מסוימת פעם אחת משפיעה 10 על התוצאה, נגיד Awake הוא 10, אז הפעמים שהמילה תשפיע 20 אופס.
שלוש פעמים תופיע 30 ולכן האפקט הוא לא. נניח כן, האפקט הוא לא לינארי.
נכון, זה מין משהו שאמור באיזושהי צורה לפחות.
כנראה לא לעלות בצורה כן לא. הנגזרת לא קבועה.
היא כנראה יורדת וזה כנראה רעיון לא טוב.
לכן מה בדרך כלל עושים? אם כן רוצים להכניס פי CNBC ובכל זאת להישאר בינארי?
יש משהו במציאות? לא. זו הדרך הסטנדרטית לעשות את זה.
זה פשוט עניין של פרקטיקה. זה הופיע, לא הופיע, לא הופיע נכון.
ונגיד שאת רוצה גם להכניס תדירות באיזושהי צורה. אז מה שעושים לפעמים עושים פילינג.
כלומר יש לך בן שאומר המילה הזאת? את אומרת ככה?
אז יש לך feature שאומר. Feature שאומר המילה לא יודע מה ג'ודה הופיע, לא הופיע אף נגיד הופיע פעם אחת מול נגיד לא הופיע.
ויש לך פיצ'ר שאומר נגיד הופיע לפחות עשר פעמים, או אולי אפילו משני הצדדים זה חסום.
את כאילו מחלקת אם היא מופיעה בין אחד לעשר אז פיצ'ר הזה נדלק בין 11 ל 20.
הפיצ'ר הזה נדלק וכן הלאה.
אז מה שנקרא קוראים לזה binding פשוט כאילו לחלק את זה ל כן לחלק את הסקלה לחתיכות ואז כאילו לכל אחד מהם אתם יכולים לתת wait אחר.
כן, אתם יכולים להגיד שמעל 50 זה שווה X נקודות, אבל בין 40 ל 50 זה שווה איזשהו מספר אחר.
אז זה הדבר. פרקטיקה יותר מקובלת עדיין, כמובן השאלה איך מוגדרים הבין.
בסדר. יפה.
אבל כן, אלה בהחלט פיצ'רים. פיצ'רים מקובלים וקיימות.
אבל יש כמובן מספר בעיות, למרות שעל זה צריך לומר ככלל ספר קוויק and Death הוא כבר מתחיל לעשות את העבודה.
כן, הוא מתחיל. לפחות הוא מזהה איזה מילים יש להם, מביעות איזשהו סנטימנט יחסית ברור.
נכון, רואה שהם מופיעים עוד ועוד ואת הגזם שמכילים את התוכן שהם יחסית חיוביים או שליליים, ובטח אם אתם לוקחים גם תדירות.
כן מופיע מאה פעמים בד אבל פעם אחת גוד.
אז אולי תגידו כן, אז הבד הוא יותר חשוב מהקוד.
בסדר, איכשהו תשחרר את זה כבר. ייתן לכם איזשהו סיגנל.
אבל לזה יש כל מיני בעיות ואחת מהם באמת כמו שאירעה ער קודם.
יש עניין של סרקזם, נכון, עניין של סרקזם.
זה למשל דוגמה אחת ששם לכאורה בעצם אם אנחנו לוקחים את זה במושגים שדיברנו קודם שמחלק לחתיכות וגם לתת סנטימנט לחתיכות וגם לתת לשלם,
אז בעצם זה טקסט שאולי תסתכלו על כל חתיכה ממנו הוא נראה או ניטרלי, אולי אפילו חיובי, אבל סך הכל מבינים שזה לא הכוונה בכלל.
יש כאן איזה משהו אירוני. אז נגיד למשל פרחים מביאים עם פרפיום זה גיד אפיון winning this case itself, Darling, Prince please where.
התיאטרון אקסקלוסיבי? Take the windows that. אוקיי, אז כפי שאתם רואים, אם הייתם קוראים רק את ההתחלה נכון או זה סך הכל אין כאן.
אין כאן שום מילה שמביעה זה משהו. כן, לסגור את החלונות.
אמירה כמו משהו דחף כל כך גרוע בהכרח. לפעמים זה רעיון די חיובי, אבל ברור כאן מה הכוונה.
כן, כאן יש ריוויו של אוטו מוביל.
String הוא העתיד של CFS.
כפי שאתם רואים בתמונה ירון דבליו והעומד שמו interesting מקומיות is now that if something.
תטעו, אני לא יודע אם צ'סטר Window עם Missing out פוסט ניסוי ויונה עם never וכאן נגמר.
אוקיי, אז יש כל מיני דברים כאלה אז זאת בעיה דיי אחרת.
זה מה שנקרא Started expect nations. כלומר מין כאלה דברים שהתהפכו.
כן כמה כמו למשל איי לאב טום קרוז, היי Big Fat the Movie was incredible.
קשה, אבל בסוף זה היה פלופ מוחלט כי לא יודע מה, כי הסוף היה דאוס אקס מכינה משהו נורא ו או Order.
אנג אפקט איך הדברים מופיעים, באיזה סדר זה גם יכול להשפיע?
אולי הסוף יותר חשוב מההתחלה כל מיני דברים כאלה.
כן, דפים שבברלין זה אותו רעיון.
כן עצם זה product וזה אפס grade ספורטינג.
אז Well אני לא אומר סתם פרפורמנס. הוא עבר התקנת הודעה.
אוקיי, אז גם כאן יש מין נטייה שאולי היינו רוצים לקודד אותה.
הפיצ'ר שהרבה פעמים בסוג כזה של מבנה של רביו הסוף הוא אולי יותר חשוב מההתחלה.
אם רוצים לתת סנטימנט להכל. אוקיי, זה מגובות מטבע הדברים לא יכול לתת לנו.
אז אנחנו צריכים משהו שלוקח בחשבון מבנה קצת יותר מורכב.
עוד בעיה זה שלילה כן שלילה.
אז הרבה פעמים נכון, יש לנו יכולת בשפות טבעיות לשלול לשלול חלקים מהמשפט מילים חלקים יותר גדולים את כל המשפט וזה יכול לגמרי לשנות את הסנטימנט.
נכון ברור. האינטרנט לייקוס Movie בטא. היי וכן הלאה.
אז כן, בגדול היינו רוצים שהדי דנט כן או הנוט או הדי דנט או מה שזה לא יהיה שם יחול על לייק.
נכון? לא יכול על מה שאחראי. הבט אולי נכון כי לפחות הוא לא שולל אותו באופן זה.
אוקיי, אבל מה לעשות שאם יש לנו סנטימנט שכן יש לנו בגוף בורג מאיזשהו סוג?
אז מה? אז מה יקרה אז?
בגדול. נגיד בטח אם זה מילים בודדות אז דידן בפני עצמו.
כנראה לא יהיה לו סנטימנט מאוד ברור. נכון, זה סתם שלילה.
מי יודע איזה סנטימנט מי אליי יהיה לו סנטימנט חיובי.
אז סך הכל אולי זה יראה די חיובי. כן אה didn't lock?
אז מה לפעמים עושים כדי בכל זאת לעשות את זה מהיר ופשוט עושים מין כזה?
Hack של להגיד אוקיי מופיע Not אז תכניסו בעצם תהפכו את המילים תשנו אותם, תעשו במקום לייק תקראו לזה לייק פריים או משהו כזה כן תסמנו אותם.
כל לייק שמופיעים אחרי not אוקיאנוס שמופיע אחרי Not או movie שמופיע הכי נוח ואז הפיצ'ר אחר מובי שלא מופיע.
חיים כן ותמשיכו לעשות את זה נגיד עד הפסיק הבא או עד סימן הפיסוק הבא או משהו.
תכתבו כל מיני דברים ספיישל וכאילו תשנו את המילים בעצם כך שהכניס את הנגישות, הקושי עם זה כמובן, או שדבר ראשון שלילה זה דבר די מסובך.
כן, יש לה סקופ די מורכב. לא קל להבחין מתי זה אומר משהו שלילי, מתי זה כאילו מתי זה שולל?
זאת אומרת אפשר אם אתם מבינים מה התחביר של השפה, אבל לא סתם עם איזשהם רגולריים פשוטים, יש גם הרבה דרכים להביע שלילה או סוג של כן היפוך כזה.
היפוך פוליטי נגיד יפה אותו כאן ועם פה את האנס, נכון?
אז זה מין פיל תוקן. ואיזה מין צורת שלילה אחרת בעצם?
למרות שזה לא ממש משתמש בנוט או didn't know או כן או דברים כאלה או nothing כן I don't think anyone קוד הב Daniel Battery צד נכון?
אז כאן יש שלילה. בוא נשים לב. יש כאן שלילה.
יש כאן מילה שהיא טובה, נכון? אחרי זה better המילים באמצע לא חושב שהן מאוד ברורות.
Pink אין לי וואן. הם לא נראה מילים מאוד ברורות מבחינת הסנטימנט.
אז מה? סך הכל יש לנו better ושלילה, כלומר שלילי.
אבל מה דעתכם? אתם קוראים את המשפט הזה חיובי?
נכון? הקטע שיש פה משהו קצת יותר מורכב זה כימות כזה, נכון?
אם הייתם כותבים את זה כן נוסחה לוגית אז הייתם כותבים שם איזה כמה נכון ל.
אני חושב שלכל בן אדם היה כן איזה משהו כזה יותר מסובך שאם הייתם באמת, אבל למצוא את הנוסחה הזאת זה לא פשוט.
כן, זה לא סתם מיסטיקה פשוטה עם Regular expression.
זה הסקופ. קשה לי לפעמים לקבוע.
I don't like dx position in this otherwise excellent fear.
נכון, כאן זה excellent. באמת excellent לא not excellent.
אבל איך מבחינים בזה? צריך להבין משהו לגבי התחביר והמבנה של המשפט.
אז אנחנו צריכים לקחת בחשבון דברים קצת יותר מורכבים.
כנראה שלא יספיק לנו לא בגבוה וגם לא by גרם.
זאת Try גרם וגם לא כל מיני יוריס ספיקות פשוטות.
הם יתנו לנו משהו. אם אנחנו צריכים משהו מאוד מהיר, אולי זה מספיק טוב,
אבל ברור שצריך באיזושהי צורה לקחת את המבנה הכולל של המשפט בחשבון ולמצוא מערכות שמסוגלות לעשות את זה, וזאת בעצם תהיה המשימה הבאה שלנו.
אנחנו נתחיל לעסוק במה שנקרא סיקוונס Models.
כן, כלומר מודלים שנותנים רצף של פרדי קצוות.
כן, שזה בעצם יהיה כן.
הצעד הראשון בעיסוק שלנו, מה שנקרא structure production, שזה באופן כללי לחזות אוסף של פרדי קצוות שיש ביניהם תלות אוקיי, שהם קשורות אחת לשנייה.
זה לא שאפשר כל אחת מהם לחזות בפני עצמה. יש איזשהו קשר ובזה נתחיל לעסוק עכשיו.
אז עוד שאלות לגבי הפרק הזה? אוקיי.
אוקיי. יפה.
אז אנחנו נתחיל בדיון שלנו עם מודלים שנקראים Hidden Makers Model או Home.
מי מכם כאן שמע את המושג או נתקל לפמפם?
היום מלמדים את זה בביולוגיה חישובית. נציגי ביולוגיה חישובית עזבו כבר כאן.
אוקיי, אז אולי הם מכירים את זה בסדר. אנחנו נתחיל מהתחלה.
אז הבעיה שתלווה אותנו כן, הוא אחת משתי הבעיות.
כן, אחת משני טסקינג המשימות המוטלות שילווה אותנו בדיון הדיון הקרוב זה בעצם Party speech tag.
כן, תיוג חלקי דיבר שזאת נחשבת אחת הבעיות הבסיסיות ביותר מעין אחת שכבות הניתוח הבסיסיות
ביותר שהרבה פעמים עושים על טקסט כשמקבלים אותו כדי לנסות להבין קצת ממה שקורה בו בעבר,
בוודאי היום עדיין כלי מאוד פופולרי וגם כלי די חזק כפי שאנחנו נראה בהמשך.
אז מה הרעיון? מה זה תיוג חלקי? דיבר אז חלקי דיבר בלי לנסות להגדיר את זה בצורה לגמרי מדוייקת,
כי פשוט אין כל כך הסכמה על מה זה בדיוק, אבל פחות או יותר מה שזה אומר זה קטגוריות שאתם נתקלתם בהם.
קטגוריות דקדוקיות כאלה של high level כמו שם, עצם, נאום באנגלית כן או שם פרטי,
מה שנקרא לפעמים פרופר non לעומת common נרדפים גם לשמות עצם שהם לא שם כל מיני Once ומסכן פעלים.
גם להם יש תתי סוגים. נכון פרופילים בזמן עבר בזמן הווה, פעלים בגוף ראשון, פעלים בגוף שני שלישי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
מילות יחס או באנגלית Participants כן, כמו אין און אנד over וכן הלאה.
אדוורדס כן, תואר הפועל כמו אתם זוכרים את הדברים האלה.
כן, נכון, במהירות, באיטיות, בחופזה ונוקשות וכן הלאה ובאנגלית.
הרבה פעמים מסיימים באל Y, אומר לאו. דווקא לפעמים לא.
מאוד וכדומה. HTTPS של תארים כן כמו גבוה נמוך, כן לבן, אדום וכולי באנגלית active ועוד דברים אחרים.
אז אין בדיוק סט אחד לגמרי סטנדרטי, אבל סך הכל זה הרעיון, ומה שאנחנו רוצים לעשות במשימה הזאת זה לקחת טקסט, לקבל איזשהו String של טקסט מחולק לתוכן.
אוקיי, מחולק למילים. בדרך כלל אנחנו נחזור רגע.
נניח שהוא מחולק ממש למילים ולכל אחד מהם לתת את הקטגוריה שלו בקונטקסט בו הוא נמצא, אוקיי, לפי ההקשר בו הוא נמצא.
ולמה חשוב לי להדגיש לפי ההקשר בו הוא נמצא, בגלל שהרבה פעמים למילים מסוימות יכולים להיות כמה חלקי דיבר אפשריים בתלות בקונטקסט,
אז למשל תהיה ואם כן סקסיסטי ואני אז עוד אולג'ואן The Board הנה Non אקזקיוטיב board.
מדובר באיזה מצגת עם קוד האקט או וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אז זה כאן איזשהו אוסף של קטגוריות? לא בדיוק חשוב עזר, אבל הנקודה היא פייר וינקל מסומן כאן כשם פרטי.
Sexy שומן מסומן ככמות Years מסומן כאומן, כלומר כשם עצם ברבים וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
כן, ואתם שמים לב שחלק מהמילים כאן בהקשרים אחרים עשויים להיות בקטגוריות אחרות.
נכון, למשל Publishing כן, כאן זה כתוב כן, כאן זה כתוב כבר.
למרות שזה פשוט. כן, אולי גם זה קצת בעייתי.
בוא ניקח את זה משהו יותר. בואו נגיד אור כן, סקסי וטיפה הגיוס עוד.
אז עוד ספר. כתוב כאן Active, אבל עוד יכול להיות נגיד גם Now נכון?
כמו תיאור כן וכן לדוגמה או נגיד כן, מה אנחנו עוד מסתכלים כאן תכף תיכף?
כל מיני דוגמאות. ממש אס.
אמ. אמ. כן, board אז זה יכול להיות להלין, אבל זה יכול להיות גם במקרה כאן דריקטוריון וכו.
המדד דיוק שלנו, המדד. אבל נרצה שלנו זה בדרך כלל פשוט כן דיוק.
כלומר כמה מתוך המילים בטקסט קיבלו את הפונקציה הנכונה חלקי סך כל המילים בטקסט.
אוקיי, פשוט אחוז המקרים שתיקנו באפל הדיקציה שלו.
אוקיי. Named entity אקוגני שן.
זאת בעיה שנתקלנו בה כבר. כן, אנחנו רוצים לחלק את הטקסט בהינתן טקסט כמו קופץ, עוד פריים קו וכן הלאה.
אנחנו רוצים לסמן סוגריים ולכל אחד מהם להגיד אם הוא Company person location וכן הלאה,
ולשים לב שגם הבעיה הזאת הרבה פעמים מתמודדים איתה, או הדרך שמבטלים אותה, היא גם על ידי מתן של פרטי דיקציה לכל אחת מהמילים.
איך בעצם? מה שעושים זה נגיד שיש לכם לשם הדוגמה אוקיי, שתי קטגוריות אפשריות לנינטנדו Company זה לוקיישן, נגיד כל שאר אני נתתי.
לא מעניין אתכם לצורך הדיון כרגע. אז אתם בעצם מייצרים אוסף קטגוריות חדש שמכיל את Now entity.
כן, שזה אומר המילה הזאת היא לא חלק משם. אוקיי, לא חלק משם פרטי ולכל אחת מהקטגוריות נגיד במקרה שלנו Company בלוקיישן אתם בעצם יוצרים שני Layout.
אחד הוא סטארט של אותו הלייבל והשני הוא continue של אותו הלייבל.
אז יש לכם עכשיו Start company וקטינים company start location continue.
ועכשיו אתם יכולים להחליף את הסימון עם הסוגריים שהיה לנו קודם בסימונים כאלה, וזה בעצם זה לגמרי שקול.
כן, כי אם נגיד אתם מסתכלים כאן, פרופיט שורד את בוינג קור.
איזה ליטופים. פודקאסט טה טה טה on wall street וכן הלאה.
אז מה שאתם רואים זה שהרבה מילים כאן סווגו כאן A.
נתתי, אבל נגיד בואינג סווגה כסטארט של Company וכור סווגה כקמפיין יושב Company.
מה שזה בעצם אומר זה אומר שהם ביחד מהווה תנאי Identity.
איפה נסגרים הסוגריים? במילה האחרונה שיש שם Continue של כן של אותו הסוג בעצם.
אז כל פעם שאתם, אם נגיד יש לכם שני סוגריים צמודים, נגיד היה כתוב לכם.
אני לא יודע מה apple microsoft.
אז במקרה שם היה לכם start company וגם המילה הבאה היא start complete.
אבל אין זה רק דבר אחד כמו בוטנקו.
אז יהיה לכם start company continue. ככה בגלל זה אתם צריכים שני לייבלים לכל אחד בסדר כדי שתדעו להבחין בין שני המקרים האלה, אבל בגדול זה די פשוט.
אז זה תיוג שהוא לגמרי שקול. לשים סוגריים לא, לא חופפים סוגריים, הם לא חופפים ולתת להם labs אז בגלל זה גם זה?
הרבה פעמים חושבים עליו פשוט כבעיה של סיכון לייבלים כי זה פשוט ניסוח לחולשה.
בסדר, עכשיו בוא טיפה נדבר על זה יותר לעומק.
על פרטי ספיץ אקסס. בגדול פרטי ספיץ סטייג.
כן, הדרך שלפעמים חושבים עליהם זה כמין קטגוריות שהם סוג של מחלקות שקילות פחות או יותר ביחס לזה.
כלומר, הם יוצרים קטגוריות או מחלקות שקילות של מילים שיכולות להופיע באותם סוטים דקדוקיים
באותם הקשרים דקדוקיים מאוד דומה הקטגוריות של המעברים שהיה לנו שבוע שעבר.
אם אתם זוכרים את המאמר על של פרננדו פריירה, למה זה היה שם?
Colors קלווין, IDE, סעיפי הוי אסלי? אז גם שם הוא ניסה לחפש קטגוריות שונות של קטגוריות מהסוג הזה הם סוג של משהו דומה לפרטי Speech.
כן, אז נגיד למשל, אני אומר בדה דוג אני יכול לשים שם Black reading report.
אני לא יודע מה כן.
כן פריטי וכן הלאה, ולכן כולם הם איכשהו קטגוריה, ובקטגוריה הזאת זה גם אותם קטגוריה של מילים פחות או יותר שיכולה להופיע אחרי The Dog is.
כן, וכנל לגבי The Cat. עוד לקצה ודלקת Where is.
ואני יכול גם כאן להסתכל איזה מילים יכולות להופיע שם.
ואני גם יכול לראות איזה מילים יש להם. נטייה של ER כן est כלומר הטייה מורפולוגית.
כן להפוך משהו לאט יותר כאילו big bigger biggest ואנגרי שנייה אחת hunger hands.
ואז אני רואה. והרעיון של party speech זה שאם אני רואה שאותה קטגוריה של מילים פחות או יותר מופיעה גם כאן פילרים אפשריים לסלוק אלף, גם פילרים מפגרים.
ב גם בסד ג, גם בשפות ד וכן הלאה. אז אני אומר אלה בעצם קטגוריה דקדוקית אחת ואני קורא לה High tech.
נגיד במקרה כזה. עכשיו כמובן שחלקכם עשויים ישר להתרעם ולהגיד נגיד לא כל המילים שהם אנשי כתיב גם אפשר להפוך אותם ל.
זה מה שרצית לומר או לא. כאילו מי שעושה את זה בעצם רק על הזין.
אני יודעת לדבר הזה.
כן. המשמעות היא סרט. ממקום אחר לגמרי.
וזה נכון. לא, לא גם לחלוטין.
כן. אז למרות שזאת שאלה אם יודע אם הסיבה שאנחנו מבינים אותו זה כי אנחנו מכירים את המילים או כי אנחנו.
נכון, אבל יש באמת שפות שיש להם סדר מילים יותר חופשי.
א. עברית יותר חופשייה מאנגלית, נכון? לא לגמרי, כי זה עדיין יישמע קצת מוזר.
אני לא יודע להגיד. מוזר. זה נשמע נגיד או כל מיני דברים כאלה, אבל זה בערך כאילו זה לא כל כך גרוע כמו באנגלית.
כן או את התפוח הכל הילד הזה.
גם זה איכשהו גם בסדר. נשמע קצת מוזר, אבל זה עובר.
אבל יש שפות שהן ממש חופשיות עם הדברים האלה כמו לטינית לדוגמה.
כן, לא לגמרי, אבל כאילו יש עוד דרגה מאוד גבוהה של זה.
ואז הדקדוק שם עובד קצת אחרת.
אז באמת ההגדרה הזאת היא הגדרה קצת חלשה מדי, רק לצרכי הדיון שלנו.
אבל מה שחשוב לי לומר זה שגם ההגדרה הזאת, מצד אחד יש בה כוח,
כי אפשר לנסות לחלץ את הפעלת Speech פה בצורה אוטומטית על ידי איזשהו סוג של class string, קצת בדומה למה שדיברנו בספר הקודם.
מצד שני, התבניות שימוש כן והתפוצה היא לא כל כך נקייה כמו שכמו שכתוב כאן כן.
אז למשל, בוא נסתכל למשל על על מילים שבדרך כלל נהוג לחשוב עליהם כעל ג'קטים באנגלית, נגיד Matter.
כן, כמו את District, את filter וכן הלאה.
יש כאן דוברי אנגלית ילידים בכיתה בערך.
מה דעתך על דרדס? כריס הוא אתר נורא, נכון, אבל אל תדאגו, אז סין בסדר, לא.
למה לא? אז בקיצור, זה סיפור מסובך מאוד.
מי שמתעניין בתחום הזה יש ספר מעולה שנקרא Radical Construction, מקרה של וויליאם קרופט שכתב בדיוק על הנושא הזה, והוא בגדול טוען שאין באמת כזה דבר.
קטגוריות סינטטיות זה הכל. חייב לעבור דרך סמנטיקה צבועה.
לא משנה, לא ניכנס לדיון כאן, אבל זאת איזושהי הגדרה שאפשר להתחיל לעבוד איתה.
הקושי עם זה במקרה של בהקשר של Parts of speech זה באמת של מילים מסוימות.
עשויות עשויים להיות הרבה מובנים שונים שמקבלים חלקי דיבר שונים.
כן, אז למשל, בואו מתרגם נגיד את המילה back וכל אחד מאלה מדביק דור אחרת.
כן, כלומר טוב. Only back כמו לא יודע מה פטפטנים back.
יובל שגב כן. ווינדוס is back חזרה, כלומר Advanced.
ומה עם promise the back the bill? לגבות כלומר פה?
אוקיי, אז אולי הרבה מילים הם לא עד כדי כך מבלבלות, אבל בהחלט יש הרבה מאוד המגיעות באנגלית.
בין קטגוריות דקדוקיות שונות, שלא לדבר על זה שלפעמים מילים הם חלק משם ואז הם פשוט שם פרטי של משהו או מישהו, ואז גם משנה את הקטגוריה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
ואנחנו רוצים לבחור את הפרט Speech שמתאים באותו הקשר ספציפי באותו Instant ספציפי של המילה.
אז איך נעשה את זה? אוקיי, איך נעשה את זה? אז יש לנו קצת מידע על זה.
עבדו על הבעיה הזאת הרבה ומסתבר שיש לנו קצת מידע על מה יכול לעזור לנו כאן, איזה סוג פיצ'רים יכולים לעזור?
אז דבר ראשון מאוד חשוב לדעת את הקשר.
כלומר איזה מילים מופיעות מופיעות, באיזה התפלגות עם מחלקות שונות?
מה הכוונה? אז למרות שנגיד Back אולי באמת הוא די נפוץ, נראה לי גם כגב, גם כחזרה, גם אולי אפילו כן לתמוך וכן הלאה.
אבל הרבה מילים, למרות שיש להם כמה קטגוריות אפשריות, יש אחת שהיא יותר דומיננטית.
אוקיי. או אולי מספר קטן שיותר דומיננטי. למשל, בוא נסתכל פה על המשפט בגרסאות באטמן יסודי.
אוקיי, אז בגדול נגיד למשל שזה יכול להיות גם בזמן עבר, נכון?
ראה בעבר יכול להיות גם מנסר, כלומר כרגע, וגם יכול להיות מסור שזה נע.
אוקיי, אבל אני חושב שבהרבה טקסטים נראה לי שלראות כנראה יותר נפוץ משימוש במספרים.
תלוי בתחום, אבל זה בהחלט נשמע סביר.
מן נכון, יכול להיות גם נאום כמו אדם, איש משהו, וגם יכול להיות פועל שאומר איש לאיש נכון, בדיוק לאיש אז זה גם פועל.
מצד שני, כנראה ברוב רובם של הטקסטים, מה יהיה דומיננטי יותר?
איזה מובן שם עצם נכון? אז אולי אנחנו לא רוצים לתת הסתברות אפס לפועל, אבל בהחלט יותר נפוץ וכן הלאה.
מילים אחרות עשויות להיות כמעט US כמו Yesterday, למרות שגם הוא נגיד שם של שיר של הביטלס.
אז אולי גם זה יכול להיות, אבל כאילו בגדול יפה אז זה דבר ראשון.
זה חשוב לנו לדעת כמה סביר שכל מילה תופיע בכל קטגוריה.
זה דבר אחד, אבל יש כאן עוד דבר עוד פרט מידע שהוא קריטי,
בוודאי אם אנחנו מסתכלים על מילים שלא הופיעו בטריינינג Data כמעט או לא הופיעו בכלל בטריינינג Data.
כן, אנחנו לא יכולים לצפות, בטח בסופר ויי Settings.
תחשבו על זה. אנחנו הולכים עכשיו לעשות סופר ווייס learning. לכן לצפות שכל המילים יופיעו בצורה מספקת בדאטה שתויגו ידנית או לא משנה סמי אוטומטית.
אז אנחנו צריכים להיות מסוגלים גם להגיד משהו על מילים שלא הופיעו הרבה פעמים Data כבר לא הופיעו בכלל.
וכן, מסתבר מה שבא לעזרתנו זה שהרבה פעמים יש קשרים בין הקטגוריות של מילים סמוכות.
אוקיי, אז לדעת את הקטגוריה של מילה מסוימת יכול לתת לנו אינדיקציה חשובה לגבי הקטגוריה של מילה שמגיעה לפני או אחריה, וכן הלאה.
אז למשל כן, אז למשל זה אוקיי, יכול להיות כמה דברים.
נכון, זה יכול להיות גם רונאן כמו עץ Disgusting, נכון?
כאילו מין כינויי גוף כזה, משהו שמחליף את הנושא של המשפט נגיד או את עושה זה יכול להיות ואת כמו כאן, איך הייתם מתרגמים אותו במשפט הזה?
ברסון דת מן יסודי הזה. אז זה נכון?
דת כן להבין מזה אז זה נקרא דטרמיניזם?
כן, הקטגוריה מידע ויש את ואת של כמו בגלל שזה בת הזוג או הזעיר וזה של הכיתה או משהו כזה.
נכון, זה נקרא קון ג'נקשן. בסדר, אז יש כאן לפחות שלוש קטגוריות שונות של TAT שאפשר להבחין ביניהם.
ומה שנחמד כאן, אז איך מבחינים ביניהם? לא רוצים תמיד לנחש את המושג Likely, נכון?
כי לפעמים זה לא. Most likely. לא most likely וקטגוריות ולפעמים אנחנו פשוט לא יודעים מה most likely category, כי זה לא אופיין מספיק פעמים.
אבל אם אנחנו יודעים שנגיד באותה מילה זה הופיע, הופיע נגיד לפני Num כמו כאן, אז נגיד דבר אחד זה די פוסל שזה זה שזה פרנה כן, שזה בעצם תחליף.
נגיד לכן לנושא או מושא כמו What is wonderful?
אוקיי, אז כי אז זה אתם לא חיים אחרי זה כזה שאומר נכון שאומר זה להגיד כלב כן או איש או משהו זה לא כל כך עובד.
אתם יכולים להגיד פועל נכון כמו date works.
כן, אבל אתם לא יכולים. אז אוקיי, אז אם אנחנו יודעים שמה שבא אחרי זה זה None.
זה אינדיקציה טובה לזה שלפחות אחת האפשרויות נפסלה.
לדוגמה כן או נגיד כן או ניקח כאן דוגמאות אחרות.
אז נגיד למשל, אם אנחנו יודעים שאסור, אוקיי, אם נגיד היינו אומרים שביל כאן זה לחייב, כלומר חייב בציווי כמו בירדמן או משהו כזה הוא יגיד את זה.
אבל אוקיי, חייבו, אז כנראה שזה לא יהיה במשמעות של פועל נכון, כי מה זה אומר בכלל?
אבל אם אנחנו יודעים שזה ביל השם הפרטי אז דווקא מאוד יכול להיות שזה זה פועל.
כן. ואם אנחנו יודעים שזה שם פרטי ביחיד זה גם כנראה לא יכול להיות סוג של לנסר, כי אז זה מה זה היה.
סוס נכון? כאילו אם זה או משהו כן זה לא יהיה לנסר כי זה צריך להיות מוטה.
אז בקיצור אתם מבינים, יש לנו המון רמזים שר המילים אז איכשהו יש פה אילוצים, נדע.
אז חוץ מזה אנחנו יכולים גם להשתמש ועוד כל מיני דברים כמו איזה מילים הם upper case, כלומר case.
למה זה לפעמים עוזר לנו להבין את שמות בדיוק שמות הם יהיו באפר קייס פי פיקסל ספק case.
כן, אם מילה מסתיימת ביידי לא בטוח שזה פועל, אבל לפעמים זה אומר את זה נכון.
אבל לפחות זה אומר איזושהי נטייה אל Y. גם לא חייב להיות שזה דבר, אבל זה נותן וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אפשר לראות עם המילה יש באותן נקודות כמו יו נקודה S נקודה A והיא באפר קייס.
אז זה כנראה סימן די טוב שזה ראשי תיבות נכון וכן הלאה.
כל מיני דברים כאלה מספרים. אולי זה כן זה גם נותן.
ואו קיי ועכשיו אנחנו. מה שאנחנו צריכים לעשות זה איכשהו לחבר.
בואו אפילו נעזוב שניה את הפיצ'רים האלה. כן, רק ניקח את שני הראשונים שהם בדרך כלל העיקריים באנגלית לפחות.
אוקיי, שזה איזה מילה מופיעה, עם איזה קטגוריה ואיזה רצפי קטגוריות הם סבירים או לא סבירים?
בסדר, אז אנחנו אומרים אוקיי, ברור כשם זה נשמע סביר.
כן, BR כפועל זה גם אפשרי. נכון, סוק פועל בעבר זה בסדר גם כפועל זה אפשרי.
כן, זה תוך כדי טרמינל הוא בסדר. מין יכול להיות גם none, גם var, אבל אולי זה פחות נעדיף אותו כי באמת אמרנו שמן כבד כבר מזה אנחנו אומרים כן,
זה אפשרי הירוק, אבל מן כבר זה כבר ככה זוכה להרמת גבה.
נכון, יסודי עבר בסדר, אז אנחנו אומרים טוב, הירוק כבר נראה לנו לא משהו, אבל האדום נראה בסדר.
והאמת שגם הכחול, רק מבחינת רק מבחינת המילים הבודדות.
כל מילה בפני עצמה נראה די בסדר. כן, נסביר זה לחייב סע, זה מסודר, בסדר.
ואת זה Construction. כן, יכול להיות כמו שאמרנו מן זבוב.
אוקיי, אמרנו, אולי גם זה קצת פחות. אבל נגיד, אם היינו שמים פה מן כנאום אז זה היה כן בסדר וישר דייב, אדווארד וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז בקיצור, במקרה כאן מה?
אנחנו אומרים זה שבעצם הסיבה שאנחנו פוסלים את היות או אנו חושבים שירוק הוא לא כל כך טוב, זה בגלל שהמילים שבו לא כל כך מסתדרות לא כל כך מסתדרות.
אוקיי. הכחול הוא דווקא רצף הרצף, המילים בו.
אה סליחה. ועוד דבר שלא טוב בירוק לא ירוק הוא גם לא טוב מסיבה שנייה שזה מבחינת הרצף.
כן, כי אם תשימו לב יש פה איזה דטרמיניזם שזה מידע לפני עיוור.
כן כאילו דת מין רק ששמתי אחרי זה פועל לא כל כך עובד טוב ויש לי וזה זה זה הרבה תלוי.
זה קורה לפעמים אבל הרבה פעמים זה לא כל כך טוב. אז קיצור הירוק גרוע גם מהבחינה הזאת וגם מהבחינה הזאת.
הכחול הוא בסדר מבחינת המילים, למרות שאולי קצת דודתי מבחינת המן שהוא יחסית לא סביר.
אוקיי, ומבחינת רצף הוא דווקא די בסדר.
כן, כי למשל תסתכלו על Find Mary before coming back.
אוקיי, אז Find זה פאב מרי זה טאון.
אוקיי, אולי find לא יודע מה Focus בפועל coming back.
בסדר משהו? כן, אתם לא באמת. אתם רוצים שם לא פרטי.
כן כן ג'נקשן אז גם before יכול להיות coming זה והיסודי זה a כאילו back זה yes.
בקיצור דווקא מבחינת הרצף זה נראה מתקבל על הדעת. ואז אנחנו אומרים אוקיי, הוא נראה לי אני מוכן לקבל אותו, אבל גם אמן שם קצת מפריע לי.
בסדר, בוא נראה אם יש לי אופציה יותר טובה באדום.
אנחנו אומרים הוא מצליח בשניהם. כן, כי מה קיבלנו שם?
זה בסדר? So כרעל בסדר Dead כן, טרמינל בסדר.
מקנרו בסדר, ישר די בסדר וגם name ו terminal advanced זה נשמע בעצם בסדר.
יש הרבה דברים שיכולים להגיד ככה, נכון? כן.
לא יודע מה יוסי want. צריך אבל לא יודע.
יוסי קיטקט דה פול לא יודע מה זה back או וואטאבר.
בקיצור יש כאן הרבה דברים. אז בקיצור מה שאנחנו רוצים להיות מסוגלים לעשות זה למצוא מודל שיכול לקחת בחשבון גם את זה וגם את זה.
הקושי שיהיה לנו שאיתו נתמודד בשיעור הבא. זה בעצם איך אנחנו משלבים את שניהם ביחד,
בייחוד איך אנחנו משלבים אותם ביחד כשנראה שאנחנו קצת בבעיה כאן עם לחזות את הקטגוריות כי אנחנו
אומרים אם הייתי יודע את הקטגוריה של המילה לפני ואחריי הייתי יודע את הקטגוריה שלי עצמי,
אבל גם את הקטגוריות שלהם אני לא יודע, וכדי שאני תת קטגוריות שלהם, אולי הם צריכים לדעת מה הקטגוריה שלי וכן הלאה.
אז איך בכל זאת מנהלים את הסיפור הזה? שהכל תלוי בהכל וצריך לבצע כל מיני פרדיגמות שהם כולם כפול אחד מהשני?
אוקיי, אז אם אם השני אז זה בדיוק מה שהתחיל לעסוק בו ברמה הטכנית בשבוע הזה.
אוקיי, אז להתראות. זוהי.
כן, זה לא בשמיים. בסוף השבוע ה 11 היה יכול להגיע לאלפי, אבל לא הייתה.
לכך שום בעיה. רגע, אולי שמתי את צבא הסייבר בראשון?
כן, אבל לא צריך לדעת. צריך לבדוק שאף אחד לא חייב לעשות.
אלה דברים שיש להם אופי מיוחד.
כן לא, אז לא בא לי. למרות שאנחנו כן ניתן לזה יותר דגש.
השפה. אז אני גם.
לא. אני יכול לדבר על זה. בדרך כלל זה לא נושא מאוד פופולרי יותר ספציפי.
זה מעניין אותי ספציפית. כן, זה לא. וואלה? מה מה?
כן. איי ספציפית עוסקת בעיקר במוצרים.
אם כן, אז אפשר לעסוק בזה.
זאת אומרת, זו שאלה חשובה. כאילו עוד לפני.
כי יש בעצם אנשים כמוני. יש את כל הנושא של תו כניסה.
כן, לפני. אז לוקליזציה מדבר נכון, אבל היא לאו דווקא מתאימה לפיגמנטציה לשונית.
כמו כן, משהו שהיא אומרת או רק חושבת איך הלמידה תופסת את עצמו אחרי.
אבל אפשר לדבר על זה. כל.
יש כן יש. כן, סינית כמובן.
יש המון חזרתיות בשפות שבהן יש הפרדת מילים.
כן כן. אז לא נראה לי שזה בדרך כלל.
זהו זה שאלה קצת מה את רוצה לעשות? אבל מה שמעניין אותך זה באמת או משהו הנדסי.
אז הרבה פעמים לא יעשו את זה לפני כן כי אתם רואים.
זה כאילו אם אין לך המון data אז יכול להיות שאת חייבת להבין כי בייחוד בשפות שיש להם את יודעת לא לא.
הנתיב. ואז שם עוסקים בזה.
אם יש לך ספקות שיש להם שאו שהם לגמרי כאילו.
כל קדנציה, אז כנראה שהיה טוב. כל העסק בפני עצמו.
11. הדבר הכי נכון בשוויץ סך הכל משהו שהוא מספיק טוב כדי לנצח ולא צריך.
אבל זה באמת. הקושי הוא בעיקר בשפות שיש להן מורפולוגיה יותר מורכבת בעברית וכמובן.
בדיחות. אם נלך הביתה אז שם חייבת לעשות עם זה משהו.
איזשהו סוג. אנגלית וגרמנית הרבה פעמים לא עושים שם כן.
כל פעם אני חוזרת שוב. אולי יש.
בגדול דברים שהכי קל. סטטיסטי, אבל אפילו דברים, אבל ממש פרדיגמות שלמות של נטייה זה לא משהו שאנחנו.
אלה בשנים האחרונות, ואז כל דגם בעצם כמה שהוא קופץ כן אפשר לעשות.
די לבזבזנות המוכשרים ביותר!
אסור לשכוח שיש לנו בטח את וילדים עושים את העבודה של.
יש האומרים כי יש לך מספיק. זהב.
אז השאלה שלי פסימית. אני לא יודע, כי הרי בסינית אומנם הם כותבים ברווחים אבל לא בדיוק.
אבל נכון, אין לך שום אינטרקציה כי אין מה לעשות.
כן, אבל אני עובד. אני לא מספיק עוקב אחריה.
אבל אני חושב שיש רגעים שבהם השפה הספרדית נוטה ליפול לוגיות מורכבות.
לדעתי גם שירשור לא מעט שזה יפה.
כן כן, אבל נגיד עכשיו עכשיו הסוף זה באמת כן ערבית ששם היה הסבר פשוט בעברית ושם בייחוד הדיאלקטים, הם כמעט.
אז שם הם עושים דברים מדהימים אבל בכלל במאה ה 20 לא כן רכב.
כן שנדבר על זה? כן כן. בסוף הקורס יש כמה שבועות.
זה רק ערוץ 23. אז? יש לך כבר?
אה כן. אה, אז אוקיי.